avec québec
impec on y va les gars je crois que je
crois qu'on a en direct
je crois qu'on a en direct ouais
salut à tous ça y est j g - 1 j -1 avant
la draft
or que j'aime et j - 2 bref j moins
avoir la draft et on va commencer avec
l'actualité
alors d'abord on va présenter les
personnes qui sont autour du micro
c'est à dire ben c'est à dire mal lu
bonjour bonsoir et cédric et la ii
voulait faire mieux sur mon frère
bonsoir je suis là comment vas-tu savard
et vous tu nous qui nous pardonne si on
prend cinq minutes pour parler de
l'actualité du trade qui vient d'y avoir
entre utah et memphis pas de souci
allez-y ben ton sang régiment qui qui
sort vainqueur de ce trade c'est une
question bête mais mérite une réponse
développer c'est moi je crois que c'est
ce qu'on appelle du business c'est ce
qui m'étonne ce qui m'épate au dessus de
la porte qui vont qui officialise le
fait qu'ils vont sélectionner déjà mort
avec deux fois et qui vont et qui qui
qui lui a qui ajoute des shooters
alentours de lui qui ajoute des vétérans
capable justement de lui donner un
certain code puisque mike on aurait pu
faire parce que ce que des quadeurs vous
pouvez en faire ce que ce que pour lyon
et oyonnax rennes aussi donc j'aime
beaucoup beaucoup se tuer de là pour les
deux équipes mais pour memphis lhc c'est
un changement de culture de ce
changement de ton on est reçu avec je
crois que les phases d des quizz rice
doit pas
chanter les louanges de nouveaux germes
c'est fini le great and green de manu un
vrai bel réf
qu'est ce que tu en penses toi manu est
ce que tu penses c'est beaucoup pour un
maître connaître 32 ans cap des soucis
parfois de santé
why assia il ya le contrat qu'énorme
aussi mais comme disait brel je pense
que j'ai dit oui de mines dans le sens
où men chine va être gagnant mais à long
terme et utah à court terme
est-ce que les deux équipes veulent je
pense c'était la recherche ni truc donc
jean séparant marca seul le choix était
le la vision de l'équipe était plus
visible
donc là il la ligue à ce qu'une et puis
reconstruit après je trouve que c'est un
peu un peu cher payé peut-être parce que
l ag et il reste quoi deux ans de
contrat en contrat sur moi après c'est
pas gai joueurs qui important à part
jack krauser rôle oui quand on verra pas
trop joué cette année bent avait vu du
temps à évoluer c'est pas forcément des
pièces maîtresses qui s'en vont c'est
plus d'aider à 7 bar 2 c'était vraiment
[Musique]
faut donner quelque chose pour va savoir
quelque chose et avec maicon l'île font
à peu près le seul
c'est un meneur qui de loin meilleur ami
qui veut bio
si le genre de gars qu'on n'ait besoin
pour encadrer un donovan mutuelle et
honnêtement 1,5 partant comme les
mutuelles le il me semble que le 23 et
transféré qui voit ce qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
les implications pour la draft alors tu
l'as dit ben le numéro deux c'est plus
que j'aime et que j'aimerai ndt france
le 23 qu'est ce qu'on va en faire
selon joe natale je vous dis qui est je
crois ce qui devrait faire donc on peut
parler d'eux c'est un équilibre avec sa
de wacker de catherine johnson par
exemple me surprendrait pop c'est ce
qu'il a fait l'église est maintenant et
même incompétence adoré manu est ce que
tu as une une proposition à faire au
nouveau frontoffice de memphis au 23 non
c'est mesquin ebay numéro cameron
johnson du shooteur je pense comme alim
gym au lycée s'ils recherchent en
priorité c'est que il a une petite idée
derrière la tête dans la construction
est-ce que grant williams est un joueur
100% même fils quand même au j'adore
ouais mais le même cuisse de la deux ans
du coup trois ans quand il était
justement week end à dijon qui shoote
est déjà à cinq mètres et qu'il a dû
toucher quoi ça se voit bon pourcentage
aux lancers francs ça projette un
shooter quittent petit peu mais qui peut
s'adapter pour manille on verra bien on
verra demain puisque c'est demain on
sera chez first team on le rappelle est
et on vous attend nombreux pour réagir à
la draft à partir de minuit et demi
puisque tu commences à 1h or logique
même si avant il ya des discours les
pataquès etc
c'est l'heure des bulls cédric c'est
l'heure des bulls effectivement c'est un
gros dossier
draft c'est un moment tellement de
rumeurs tous les jours que c'est
compliqué d'arriver à tous des mêlées
ouais mais mes septième choix pour la
troisième année de suite en général
depuis on n'est pas mauvais pour pour
choisir la draft donc c'est vrai laurie
markkanen va être menée le carter
juniors ça ne s'est pas trop mal passé
les deux dernières années c'est pas trop
mal effectivement avec un avec le
septième choix et il est possible qu'ils
nous restent qui nous restent également
des choix intéressants en cède donc je
pense que je pense que c'est pas si mal
que ça j'espère juste qu'on va pas
drafté un honneur oui assez intéressant
parce que qu'est-ce qui est la situation
avec les quizz dan en fait chris dunn je
pense qu'on n'y croit plus au projet
chris dunn qu'armand je pense que c'est
la fin de la fin de crise donne en tant
que titulaire en tout cas aux bulls et
je pense qu'on va plutôt en tout cas
c'est ma façon de penser qu'on est
plutôt nous aller chercher un meneur
vétéran la free agency
je vois je pense que pas de beverley ses
choix numéro 1 et je pensais je croyais
beaucoup alonso ball chez nous avant
qu'il soit drafté op leekens on en
parlait comme une possibilité si on est
la troisième équipe inclus dans le deal
et ce raté quelque chose qui n'aurait
pas déplu parce qu'il nous faut vraiment
un défenseur à côté de la ville il nous
faut un distributeur
donc c'est pour ça que pour moi garlande
notamment garland des copyrights qu'est
pas réellement encore habitué à jouer
meneur ça me paraît vraiment compliqué
de de le faire jouer
vous allez faire jouer avec avec la
vigne à terme puisque est ce que tu es
prêt à tu serais prête wattré 17e clic
pour avoir un vrai bon meneur mettant
non parce que je pense vraiment que il
ya la place dans quatre classes
on a 23 millions potentiellement 26,6 si
la nba accepte la retraite de asie
pourquoi le problème sur donc si tu vois
pas vraiment l'intérêt de près dé ce pic
alors qu'on aura des joueurs à fort
potentiel qu'ils sont
disponible pour la lettre ou et rouen
backup est con qui peuvent apprendre de
joueurs de joueurs confirmés
je pars là je parle du poste trois voire
quatre ans a pas certain mais mes
chouchous donc je vois pas en fait
pourquoi on irait drafté galande encore
moins que jamais reine où on irait draft
et kobe white ça me paraît très haut
comme choix en cette copie white donc je
suis pas fan de ces choix là moi
personnellement ok donc donc est ce que
tu as un favori ou quelqu'un sur qui tu
aurais des questions par exemple moi je
me montre pas mon favori c'est jared
culver pas ce que je fais ça serait
totalement parfait derrière autobacs
d'ingénieur en trois il pourrait lui
apprendre à shooter de façon stable et
un gros travailleur donc c'est ce qu'on
aime noah chicago
maintenant je pense sincèrement qu'il
sera plus disponible c'est un plus
disponible en 3 donc après derrière
pour en avoir parlé avec les gars tu as
j'étais pas vraiment emballé mais lui il
m'a donné tellement d'amour peur que
qu'il a réussi à me faire changer d'avis
et calmes relish pour le potentiel et je
pense qu'effectivement pour lui
apprendre d'ailleurs autoportant junior
pendant deux ans avant de pouvoir
pourquoi pas pour une place de titulaire
ça peut être intéressant
ou alors ces courses et quia en quatre
il aura en 3 4 pour moi c'est plus
simple que ça serait plus un quatrième
billet ses coûts donc ça peut vous
pouvez peut-être répondre à ma question
est ce que pour vous ça serait 1,3 ou
1,4 en nba ces coups derrière
d'ailleurs marqué 4 il aurait 5 minutes
donc il pourrait grandir absolument pas
ce qu'il vous manque
il vous manque un quatre remplaçants si
je dis pas de bêtise et de faire on n'a
aucun quatre remplaçants c'est le
barreau qui jouons autoporteur qui est
un bon client qui fait le taf en poste 4
qu'un ailier de grands grands formats
manu tulle 3 ou 4 ses coûts moi je dis à
+3 pour quelles raisons une façon de
jouer il aiguille a beaucoup plus le
l'instant le jeu d'un
23 44 ans après c'est ce qu'il a montré
avec limogés dans les différentes
équipes de jeunes en tout cas et je
pense qu'il en a après je pense qu'il
pourra défendre sur les deux postes
ouais c'est ce que j'allais dire est ce
que serait pas un cadre défensif et
trois offensives
voilà j'avais en tête du cou est donc
voué dans la danse et à la ja après
offensivement il peut jouer décalé parce
qu'il sera forcément souvent plus rapide
que non mais bon la taille du panier
donc ça peut être aussi une arme
offensive en 4 et 6 en bus il peut
gagner des minutes comme ça final c'est
tout bénéfique pour lui aussi de se
retrouver dans une équipe qui est en
reconstruction
va-t-on pas forcément grand chose de la
saison prochaine du coup il peut
travailler tranquillement et alterner 3
et 4
pour lui c'est bien et je m'inscris pour
les boules ceci parce qu'ils aident
c'est un joueur à fort potentiel
montpellier ils sont en droit d'attendre
quelque chose et puis avec mark allen je
pense ça peut jouer ensemble mark allen
peut s'écarter pas mal connu celui de la
place aussi pour apprendre arrivé au
cercle
donc quoi c'est mu lui fit est sur le
papier est intéressant c'est au 1 en 7
ça veut dire prendre un risque sur un
joueur qui est certes un fort potentiel
ben may mais qui est quand même pas 100
% de garantie c'est que tout me wade il
ya des rumeurs qui courent comme de quoi
les pauses serait intéressé mais oui moi
je trouve que c'est à fouquières faut
qu'on a collé un plein en place déjà ici
sinon j'ai pas qu'elle sas et traite un
peu surtout que la spéculation autour de
lui atteint son paroxysme cette semaine
pascale lecam vraiment extrêmement
dangereux à jouer je vous disais
regarder on comparer à la grappe 2016
ont comparé des hagan banda
mais oui moi je trouve que si on a le
choix entre un bien du hunter ses coûts
peut-être que ces coûts est légèrement
plus au plafond mais avec beaucoup plus
qu'est ce qu'on a pu on a à peu près la
même chose par exemple
cédric pour toi il faut un joueur qui va
dans le sens de l'identité de l'équipe
c'est une équipe qui a des joueurs qui
aiment courir qui aime les espaces qui
way qui c'est une équipe des spas sont
mark allen carter porter c'est cette
plutôt interchangeables tout le monde
peut un peu driver tout le monde peut un
peu passé c'est la nba moderne
après le coach milanais a été prolongée
et il a changé sa façon de jouer de lui
c'est plutôt un coach défensif et
s'adapter à son groupe et a priori les
retours qu'on assure sur ses coûts après
son or quels autres c'est qu'il a
réalisé un workout exceptionnelle avec
les bulls
et ils ont aidé les îles sont
dithyrambiques sur lui donc là je lisais
un article de questions je ne sonne
juste avant de d'être avec vous et lui
disait que des priorités et économe
heures et donc donc ça ça parait
intéressant effectivement ça me paraît
peut-être un petit pot mais qu'est-ce
qu'on qu'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on
cherche c'est ce qu'on cherche quelqu'un
qui peut jouer directement comme un
auteur bien des certitudes
ou est ce qu'on cherche un potentiel
avec delicious donc il ya moins
personnellement rédiger un peu plus de
mal au niveau de la mentalité
maintenant est ce que ces deux jours là
j'étais chez le mouillage ça peut coller
avec notre coach boyden une grande
gueule qui a un coach qui n'hésite pas
secouer les puces déjà être très
autoritaire dans qu'est ce que ça peut
coller avec avec un caractère comme
celui de ses coups je sais pas je ne
connais pas assez je sais pas si vous
pouvez m'éclairer là-dessus cgc plus là
dessus que j'ai peur parce qu'il faut qu
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qu'il faut
choyer kita où est-ce que c'est
quelqu'un qu'il faut
j'ai booster je sais pas trop un peu des
deux ouais c'est parce qu on a peut-être
un des meilleurs scouts européens en la
personne de louis kahn
donc j'ai plutôt confiance en lui
sur le choix des européens et c'est vrai
que moi tant qu'à faire je tenterai 1 je
tenterai un pari en sept jeux perdus en
7 je préfère prendre un ses coûts ou un
ourlet 10 ans est quitte quitte
effectivement a tenté un gros pari je
pense qu'on a la place pour le faire et
je pense qu'on a des joueurs en plus
justement est ce que tu as c'est pas un
peu il n'y a pas des différences de deux
timetable dans tout ce que tu nous dis
d'un côté tu vas un meneur un peu
vétérans de l'autre tu un pari est ce
que tout ça va voir un jour se met en
place c'est un jeu c'est des choses à
penser aussi quand on construit une
équipe clairement c'est l'année où il
faut qu'on la reconstruction avance
qu'on essaie de viser une place en
playoffs
une femme plaçant plusieurs centres
habilités année prochaine donc il faut
effectivement qu'on avance a qualifié ce
qui nous manque c'est des vétérans donc
mettre un meneur qui vient d'être drafté
comme titulaire ça me paraît compliqué
après à côté de ça on n'a pas de
remplaçant au poste quatre mois pas de
remplaçant poste 5
on a vraiment des trous partout au
niveau de l'équipe donc donc le 5 est
presque déjà comblé mon cas ma mère donc
c'est le moment c'est le moment
peut-être justement de prendre ce type
de joueur qui peut grandir avec l'équipe
on aurait eu un choix plus haut serait
peut-être penser différemment mais là
avec le set
et avec cette draft qui est pas
forcément profonde est-ce qu'il faut pas
essayer d'aller chercher le plafond plus
haut c'est ça ma réflexion
de toute façon aux us comme le rappelait
antoine sur twitter on lui fait coucou
et d'un chat
les équipes vont draft est généralement
le meilleur joueur disponible selon elle
sur leur big board alors ce que d'allah
de nous dire c'est que les bulls ont ces
coûts peut-être un peu plus haut que les
autres équipes sur leur board même chose
peut-être pour calver même si je crois
que le verre plat beaucoup de monde
probablement après et est ce que tu as
eu des échos sur ce qu'on pensait de
kobe wide dareus garlande et ce qu'ils
ont ne serait-ce que work out chez vous
on essaie de faire coller white au début
en fait on m'a annoncé qu'il avait une
promesse pour lui on pensait que c'était
des sommes sous les boules c'est un
dense et très fortement c'était des
bulls mais et moi j'y crois pas trop en
fait ça ça collerait pas trop avec avec
votre effectif est avec avec notre
recherche de meneur vétéran parce que
c'est à dire que derrière derrière ce
potentiel le bonheur j'étais en
honoraires et white et de même si on n'a
toujours rien fait on sait pas encore
débarrassé donne donc durer il ya un
problème de durée un problème de
bouchons au niveau 2 au niveau du poste
de manière donc je ne vois plus salée
drafté un un poste 3-4
mais bennie toi tu te tuer croit kobe
white en titulaire mans oui et j'aime
bien fait le fait je viens le fait à
chicago
je trouve que sa joie qui est
responsable qui rase et qui as été
meilleure et qui a pas besoin
nécessairement de d'avoir d'abord le
spotlight sur lui si défensivement c'est
pas c'est pas l'organe des faveurs comme
qui dirait mais ce joueur qui joue
justement on de manière responsable qui
ne mélange jamais ses rotations et et
qui je crois est un excellent complément
ou calvin et aux éau le remake canal de
shows de danse sur l'ecfa parce que ces
deux joueurs lassés de joie qui ont
besoin du ballon pour marquer et kobe
wade n'a pas nécessairement besoin du
ballon c'est aussi le joueur qui tombe
en dessous pour son âge césar cédric
avant de passer à votre choix du second
tour qui est quand même mon choix le
seuil coll 38
il ya bladers france qui te propose
turner plus arc laissent plus le pic 25
plus un futur tour de draft contre
autoporteur junior ou en faites pas pour
moi autoporteur junior c c'est elle qui
bougera pas il a apporté totalement
satisfaction à l'équipe
il convient parfaitement au roster donc
pour moi c'est malgré son gros contrat
c'est un joueur à part
à moins d'une grosse offre que je ne
bougerai pas hockey est un convaincu sur
totalement convaincu et je pense
vraiment que justement c'est quelqu'un
qui peut apporter
il peut former bas un des ailiers qui
parce que j'ai l'impression graft de à
fort potentiel au niveau des éviers et
ça me paraît être le joueur parfait pour
justement former notre futur jeune
ailier dans ma tête en tout cas dans mon
dans ma dans ma vision en tout cas de se
complaire l'adresse hockey et pour le
second tour pour le pour le second tour
moi j'ai quelques joueurs que j'aime
bien j'aime bien mac daniels
j'aime bien aussi à venir hans coated et
après on peut parler on peut tenter un
coup un john terry porter par exemple
avoir avoir au niveau des blessures
maison hantée porter par exemple ça
pourrait être un coup à tenter en 38
donc sur le profil plutôt des joueurs
accès vers les postes 4 5
c'est ça pour combler les trous et moi
je un jour je pense qu'il sera trop trop
également sérieuse base les je pense que
sa cote est en train de remonter mais ça
aurait été quelqu'un qu'on va peut-être
intéressant également avec notre avec
notre alors le oui on a essayé de
trouver pareille façon quelqu'un qui va
pouvoir qui a pouvoir être pack back up
et compléter le roster alors le 25 40
c'est une zone où je pense ça fluctue
beaucoup d'accords donc pas l'évidence
que peut-être pas ben ben manouche pas
ce que vous en pensez mais on n'en sait
pas grand chose
de la cote de base et on sait qu'il a
été bon au combat et les pipes
j'ai entendu personnellement du boss wii
à savoir qu'est ce que ça bouge je sais
pas parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'équipés
qui disent vouloir du nba ready à ce
niveau-là de la draft quelle logique
hein c'est la fin de la fin de premier
tour
ben ya plusieurs équipes qui ont
plusieurs un tour de draft souci d'ombré
par exemple mais c'est vrai et qui va
donc et les spurs à 29 mai après après
derrière par exemple on a on a on a fait
un workout avec jane howard
j'ai l'impression que sa cote elle a
complètement baissé par rapport au début
de nos débuts de c1 complètement alors
que pourtant il a fait des stats mais
dans une équipe un peu et ça me laisse
faut vous dire ce qui est et j'étais
étonné en fait qu'il ait qui n'est pas
d'essai son nom dont on sait qu'ils
soient pas retourner la saq en fait ça
m'a surpris qu'un joueur comme ça prenne
le risque de s'inscrire à la draft et
j'ai pas eu de retour sur son sourcil
workout mais j'ai l'impression que c'est
pareil c'est un joueur qui a fait pas
mal de workout et pourtant je le vois
toujours je le vois pas dans les
différentes notes
bah ouais il a pas il à papeete de
workout visiblement ni dans ce qu'il a
fait il n'a pas été très impressionnant
il n'a pas été nul mais il n'a pas été
très bons non plus aucune des combats y
est pareil que cette saison c'est qu'il
n'a pas été nul mais il n'a rien montré
de très transcendant pour l'allier donc
c'est un peu compliqué quand tu n'as
jamais de moment sur lequel tu peux de
vendre je dirais que c'est un peu
compliqué un manu qu'est ce que t'en
plans sont déjà parlé de la saison
galère mardi mais c'est vrai que c'est
pas on était surpris qu'ils retournent
pas à la fac
après peut-être que lui a dit enfin pour
lui c'est peut-être déjà tout vu je sais
pas son choix étonnant tu pense qu'il
peut être drafté sur le potentiel
puisqu'il a quand même
un profil physique intéressant ouais
mais le potentiel mois maintenant j'ai
du mal à le voir parce que ça fait quand
même une voire deux saisons qui qui
progresse plus vraiment bon il a été pas
mal gêné par les blessures quand il
était dans les équipes de france jeunes
notamment
mais je trouve qu'il n'a pas qui n'a pas
augmenté et une stagne un peu et
je pense que le si les draps pts et le
fait pas forcément beaucoup joué ou
encore plus le pénaliser c'est ça va le
ca va le [ __ ] en l'air au moins à wake
forest lors du 10 minutes dans luz 20 20
minutes mais un homme sinon qu'il aurait
joué il aurait touché la balle s'ils ont
une vieille fait que lui que
l'entraînement où les des navettes avec
l'algérie après moi je suis pas fan de
llanelli puis je trouve que ça apporte
rien mais je pense que c'est un peu plus
le pays dans quelque chose alors après
il y aura un contrat c'est sûr mais il
faudra le flambeau c'est lui qui montre
que une idée ou une idée rapidement pour
les bulls en poste 4 5e aux 38 avant
qu'on passe aux knicks lovells osman a
donc là c'est plus 3,7 au 403 cadeau
mais ok y'a du cas du vécu il ya quand
même une idée de sa place en euroligue
pas beaucoup mais il a joué il sait ce
que c'est ce que c'est le monde
professionnel je pense que ce qui peut
bien se placer là dedans autrement ou un
balai mais je pense que je pense que ce
sera parti emmanuel tu penses que c'est
une mauvaise idée
oh non non non après je suis c'est pas
le pas le nom que j'ai le plus joué pour
être honnête donc je ne vais pas
m'avancer là dessus mais c'est un joueur
qui est intéressant avec à ses immenses
en tous cas c'est pour ça que j'ai bien
aimé parce que j'ai pu en voir et je
suis pas
un spécialiste mais j'ai vraiment
beaucoup aimé james personnellement soit
et puis c'est un jour que je pense à
terme peut être écarté pour autant que
mark allen mais qui peut apporter un peu
de poudre pacing abassi le shoot suis
chef daniel c'est pas mal parce que il
pousse la balle il est grand et que
défendre plusieurs positions il a été
bon en défense
dans ces gros matchs cette année cette
joute voir physiquement ça tient parce
qu'il n'est pas manon serment 90 kg
d'ivoire qui mangent du blogueur de
l'accord qui lie au mcdo avec le guen ce
site où je suis ça peut être une belle
prise on a tu l'as en 38 général admiral
les pieds plats bon cédric je te
remercie il est l'heure de passer aux
knicks merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous et à la prochaine
deux 2 nouveaux arrivants dans ce live
tout d'abord le représentant des knicks
connais pas ton prénom négoce à antoine
antoine très bien quand antoine on
entend très fort chez basto qui le
traite comme ça et ça me laisse le temps
d'accueillir thomas du entre autres du
podcast poster dunk à l'eau thomas dont
il veut pas nous parler et nous parlera
le foot à antoine
oui moi je suis là par contre c'est on
va je vais mettre la page des knicks en
fonds pourris on a une visibilité un
petit peu sur sur la situation
contractuelle parle-nous un petit peu de
de cette situation des knicks avec
beaucoup de free à jane quand même
énormément énormément crête jetés dans
les handicaps space un peu une feuille
blanche presque
exactement un flou total même parce que
par rapport à tout ce qui est passé d 1
semaine ont aucune idée d'à quoi va
ressembler l'équipe dans dans une
dizaine de jours même c'est très
difficile à prévoir
en tout cas en ce qui concerne
simplement la draft les rumeurs ont
quand même été assez assez simple parce
que la voiture au moment où on a obtenu
le troisième choix
tout le monde était d'accord pour dire
que les knicks prendrait certainement
celui qui reste entre morante barrette
c'est à dire celui que même fils ne
prendra pas et comme les grizzlies se
sont vite tournés vers leur mourante
apparemment les rumeurs ont vite été
verbard est pour les knicks donc en cela
doive c'est quand même l'une des seules
choses de cette intersaison où la
direction semble assez clair même avant
avant demain quoi n'écouterait pas avoir
de surprise en moins
donc pour toi cr djebar est 100 pour
clément sur une petit je sais pas si
c'est de l'intox parce que justement il
vient de vient de sortir et il a dit que
que les knicks à voir l'intérêt pour lui
après c'est servir du joueur donc on
sait jamais mais c'est quand même assez
bizarre on marque des 20 minutes après
je me dis c'était aussi peut-être lié
aux rumeurs qui avaient avec les pelikan
ce qu'ils voulaient monter à la draft
pour pour peut-être prendre barrette
ceci oui bien sûr donc je pense que
c'est plus une part sécurité qu'ils ont
fait ça mais après je me dis et c'est
aussi une question pour vous est ce que
ce serait totalement fou de de prendre
garland devant devant paraître tout mort
en quoi dépendent qui l'église prenne
mais certainement certainement par être
est ce que ce serait fou ou est ce que
ce sera un gros reach te prendre car
l'homme devant barrette est ce que ce
serait fou de noël heuliez
[Musique]
l'offensive et du parrot a fait 4 points
2 passes décisives par match dans attend
que j'entends que carrière dans le
système toilettes bouchées qui était qui
est idiot que l'année dernière qui était
en fait un concours d qui pisse le plus
loin en pluie et saul williams sonne je
fais je file à éclairer les plaies c'est
sur l'échangeur il s'échangeait à ça moi
je suis 100% manu l'essai mais je crois
que c'est vraiment vraiment un joueur
qui vient répondre plus chez les knicks
qui risque
voilà tu étais tu as ta réponse un peu
biaisé qu' il ya une fan de duke et de
new york a beaucoup pour un seul homme
hier tjibaou en parlant de canadiens
antoine nous signale comme si on double
kabengele sera dans la green room soir
de la draft
c'est ça un héros en avant de la 23
c'est beaucoup c'est une grosse room en
plus sec avec les giallorossi antoine on
continue avec toi 1ère djebar est ok est
ce que est ce que tu pense néanmoins que
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait pour lâcher ce
pick 3
chaque baie n'est pas d'accord mais
abandonner s'il ya une équipe qui arrive
avec une équipe une offre n'offrent de
par un peu fade un euro fort qu'elle
qu'elle devrait l'être pour pour te
faire chanceler ce diable quand même
descendre dans l'ordre à descendre dans
la draft je suis vraiment pas fan
personnellement parce que les knicks à
risque à une équipe quand tu rates le
roster ça manque quand même de talent
est à voir dans un choix dans le top 3
ça arrive rarement à new york ce n'est
pas arrivé depuis des années même des 10
et donc je pense que il faut profiter de
cette occasion pour draft est un joueur
avec du talent surtout dans une draft où
j'entends
beaucoup que c'était une draft ou y
avait trois gros joueurs qui étaient à
shenzhen avait un au dessus du lot mais
aussi deux jours derrière donc je pense
que ça serait quand même ce serait quand
même une bonne occasion de d'ajouter du
talent dans ce roster qui en manque
cruellement
et vu les dernières rumeurs d'ailleurs
les hawks ont refusé les knicks ont
refusé l'offre des hawks il ya pas
longtemps avec les chevaux 8 et 10 j'ai
du mal à voir les knicks descendre là je
pense qu'elle fonde une victoire assez
concentré sur bar était est le troisième
choix ben tu confirmes de ce que tu as
vu aussi je pense que nous aimons les
mêmes sources
oui il ya plus d'un an
il confia plus d'avis ça serait même
très cher et romain sur le fait qu'il y
a que le bron que je veux bien échanger
contre le pit 3 un peu excessif mais
c'est clair en bon état d'esprit je
crois que thomas est enfin là allez
salut salut les gars vous l'attendez way
pourtant parfaitement très clairement
comment vas tu travailles et vous ça va
bien tu donc tu fais partie de l'équipe
poster dunk évidemment qu'on elias but
et est ce que tu contribues autre part
je me rappelle plus non pas du tout
c'est déjà beaucoup
qu'est ce que est ce que tu as une
analyse sur la situation des knicks
tiens puisqu'on est en train de parler
de ça bon on parle du tubik 3 mai toi
par rapport plus peut-être à
l'intersaison est ce que peut-être le
cam neely qui n'a aussi quelqu un petit
peu au centre de l'attention médiatique
en ce moment que cake est ce que tu as
quelque chose à dire sur un de ces deux
sujets ouais
je suis assez d'accord avec ce que vous
disiez sur sa manche principalement de
talent donc à demander l'avis du
programme bach est la seule la seule
alternative pour moi c'était vraiment si
tu voulais inclure temps peac3 dans un
trade pour prendre un très belle partie
pour donner davis mais ce qui masque est
ce qu a pas l'air de partir là dessus
après je pense que un des dangers pour
moi pour l'intersaison des knicks c'est
qu'il ya quelques top top free agent
puis quelques free edition juste au
niveau du dessous si j'étais vraiment
chronique je préférerais me dire bah on
donne des contrats d'un an quitte à ce
que ce soit d assez gros sera à des
joueurs en attendant la prochaine free
agency si jamais on n'arrive pas à avoir
des cahiers gicle wiseler crédit ou des
jours comme ça plutôt que prendre le
risque de donner des contrats de cinq
ans à kembo walker et tony butler par
exemple je pense que ce sera surtout ça
le gros point quitte à vivre un an avec
une nouvelle année un peu de temps king
avec andy barr est développé des jeunes
un peu ce qu'ont fait les lakers l'année
près près d'hébron et qui est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ça antoine et
ben moi je totalement d'accord toute
façon le front-office l'a répété à
plusieurs reprises que s'ils
n'arrivaient pas à faire venir les tops
agent que son k-way l'honneur kevin
durant fut même kevin durant est
d'ailleurs même s'ils font tenir toute
façon ça changera pas grand chose pour
la semaine prochaine qui jouera pas mais
leur but de l'algérie milite et de
dépenser l'argent sur les estrades
jeunes de seconde zone qui sont nicolas
goussé vieillot tobias harris sans leur
manquer de respect donc
donc ouais même sans donner l'argent à
des gros contrats sur un an le taux cash
space peut aussi devenir ta meilleure à
7 dans le sens où on peut l'utiliser
comme là que l'on fait hawks récemment
qu'ils ont récupéré râler un an du
contrat de dan crabe et en échanges et
de récupérer des choix de draft
comme l'ont fait les net's dans le passé
de récupérer par exemple le contrat de
mozgov même s'ils étaient en contrat
plus long ils ont récupéré russell en
échange
en tout cas le space peut aussi devenir
une a7 dans le sens où qu'on voit tous
les mauvais contrats cas dans la ligue
je peux t'en servir pour récupérer
d'autres à 7
donc je pense que ce serait plus
judicieux d'utiliser ce le captivate de
cette façon plutôt que d'utiliser sur
sur des phrases jeunes de seconde zone
et apparemment c'est le front-office va
faire ça quand même
ben il ya pas mal d'équipés je pense à
minnesota je pense à charlotte je pense
à miami je pense à detroit ont quasiment
cape town ont peut-être besoin de se
délester de leurs flics est ce que toi
est ce que toi c'est un règne qui
t'intéresse dans cette grave d'aller
d'aller acheter a entre guillemets de
d'utiliser tonkam space pour récupérer
un pic entre 10 et 15 ou est-ce que tu
as préféré des pics d année prochaine
by par exemple est incroyable le fait
d'avoir un vrai dire je suis pour un an
[Musique]
pour un travail que ça donnerait un peu
d'améliorations hockey et on va parler
peut-être un peu de franck quand même
qu'est ce que tu penses de il ya
toujours cette rumeur est échangeable
contre enfants de prendre une fin de
premier tour déduites deuxième c'est ça
ouais c'est ça c'est ce qui est sorti du
mois hier par avec le new york post est
confirmée par amp grille derrière que
normalement les niches chercherait à
récupérer une fin de premier tour et un
début de second tour pour pour franck en
échange de franck
après la rumeur échange de francs que ça
existe depuis maintenant plusieurs
semaines si ce n'est moi
les panneaux comme déjà qu il a chargés
d'agents à l'époque est là avec cette
offseason ou oui beaucoup de choses qui
sont passées on a eu beaucoup de jeunes
demis par exemple sont partis voir les
matches des finales ensemble et frank
était jamais avec eux de yavin nox et
vers robinson et jamais franck donc on a
l'impression qu'il est aussi un peu
distant de riz s'entraîne à dallas en ce
moment et puis tu as toujours tout dit
relations exquises des loups c'est sorti
hier qu'il il a l'air de bien aimer
kadima l'aisne et la laird pas forcément
porté franco dans son estime que moi ça
m'étonnerait malheureusement puisque moi
j'aimerais bien le garder mais ça
m'étonnerait que franck disputent encore
un seul match avec les knicks
mais ce qui est dommageable c'est qu'on
laisse si on les change par exemple
demain on les change donc sa valeur la
plus basse certainement puis-je je vois
pas une équipe
même fin de premier tour choisi du mal à
voir une équipe lâche un pic pour fin de
premier tour pour franck
oui demain tu vois donc si pour
récupérer un second tour je me demande
quel est l'intérêt de l'échangé quoi
pourquoi pas refaire une année leur
donner plus de responsabilités ou plus
de confiance du moins une photo qui
récupère un second tour contre franck
ben t'es d'accord excès bah oui en fait
[Musique]
des collections mais thomas est ce que
tu es encore glauque timis mhz pour la
carrière de franck tilly qui na waie
pour la carrière pour sa carrière en
général et même là je trouve que cette
situation actuelle n'est pas si gênante
que ça en fait dans la mesure où s'il
est raide et ce sera sans doute pour une
équipe dans laquelle il
un rôle plus important est là même s'il
reste à new york bon l'art effectivement
eu des donations un peu compliqué avec
l'idée qu'ils préfèrent plutôt des
dodson tirer des joueurs qui jouent un
peu 1,2 à son poste mais je pense qu'il
a une carte à jouer dans un rôle de nos
missions défensives en sortie de banc
alors bon pour l'instant ça va pas trop
tourner en sa faveur mais ça peut aussi
se retourner pour peu que les knicks
monte une équipe avec du vrai talent
offensif sur le bac courte
bapt être que ce sera plus des joueurs
comme lui ressorti banques sont
nécessaires plutôt que les joueurs que
j'ai cité juste avant donc à voir
comment ça va évoluer mais je suis
encore confiant pour retransmis un
profil pour réussir en nba pour - dans
un rôle ce n'est de role players a
minima de remplacement ok intérêts
semblent manu je te pose les mêmes
questions sur le futur de franck est ce
que tu crois toujours en le potentiel en
rappel il est drafté quoi 8e 7e 8 8 ou 9
ch et 9e à 8 de nice pc 80e - 9 nov
non non tu es 8 et des bancs du c919
ouais donc donc c'est quand même un
joueur sur lequel les knicks ont investi
de l'espoir est ce que toi tu en as
encore aussi wimbee et non je me sente
ans tombe
je pense que c'est un peu un joueur qui
va ressembler à de colo potentiel
montrent qu'un joueur monstre mais qui
est tracée pour les ennemis en fait il
est temps pour l'europe ça c'est pas
parce que je pense qu'il n'a pas le il a
pas le mot l'esprit d'un joueur qui peut
réussir en fait il n'a pas le c'est pas
un attaquant c'est pas un mec qui va
aller du panier tirer pour pour faire
des points ça ne l'intéresse pas en cet
oui je joue au basket je défends lui
donner des ballons il ne tardez pas
décisif
de gagner en fait j'ai fait et je pense
que ça on oubliait il n'a pas le seul
correspond pas c'est dommage parce que
c'est un joueur tient potentiellement
son os est depuis des années mais
qu'elle passait pour paul e pour ce nous
voilà finalement et c'est trop haut je
pense pas parce que il a montré là il a
eu des moments où il a montré qu'il est
totalement les gens qu'il a dit n'est
pas là pour rien mais je pense que s'il
a une carrière pierre et le pour moi en
euroligue premier bon ça fait réagir
dans le chase mettez lykina aux spurs et
on en reparle
c'est un bosseur antoine dit je peux
être intéressant pour n'importe quel est
il il a largement le niveau arrêté c'est
à dire il a été choisi huit
effectivement je n'ai jamais oublié plus
jeune que lui le plus jeune que j'ai dit
si on lui disait antoine surtout car ce
matin oui il est il al'âge de plusieurs
joueurs qui vont être drafté ces jeunes
c'est sûr plus jeune que deviendra
moteur par exemple et le même âge
voudrait que alexander walker ce genre
de joueurs on te demande
antoine si si kevin nox et dans les
plans sur le tchat
je crois que oui un oui oui mais parce
que les knicks et un peu qu'ils sont
envoyés au pdi kahn se contenter un
déficit donc je pense que ça prouve
qu'il a encore dans les plans quoi tient
à coeur c'est encore tôt pour abandonner
même si on attend encore deux ans du
colloque ça ça a l'air d'être encore un
peu tôt ouais c'est le bon ski et lé ton
scénario idéal le soir de la draft
il est l'heure de conclure aujourd'hui
que zion descendants 3 sinon bah
récemment bienvenue dans mon optique
morand tu vas partir en deux bulles
échanges qu il ya une heure donc ça se
prend deux barrettes entre autres
simplement prendre barrette en trois et
je vais poser à une question à benne en
55 semaines qui tu veux chez tmx
sinon il ya quelques options le deuil
aura toujours des vitesses non j'aime
bien l'idée d'avoir plus de cilaos il
est ici fait pas cent cinquante kilos à
la sortie de l'été ok voilà plusieurs
noms pour toi antoine pour essayer de te
projeter sur le deuxième tour on en
reparlera évidemment après la draft
on vous souhaite r djebar est ça a l'air
d'être un mariage qui s'annonce correcte
et ont trouvé ce type d'être passé avec
nous merci à vous pour l'invitation
merci beaucoup le compte twitter c'est
par obèse knicks et ferme à plusieurs
décomptes des knicks évidemment grosse
fanbase merci à toi merci à vous en
saurez plus on accueille le patron du
comte de fans des hawks sont un peu
moins nombreux que les fans des knicks
pourquoi est-ce que je m'attendais à ce
drame mais ils sont ils sont fidèles je
me rappelle que ton prénom de jonny
cocker pardon du rif joris mais oui
l'année dernière seulement pas fait
quand j'étais en train de gueuler parce
qu'on avait pris très bien mais la place
de dons site
c'est vrai et finalement
rétrospectivement quelle bassesse et un
treuil de win win je pense un don si tu
fait une super saison de très longues
fait une super saison
on récupère un pic de dix ans plus qui
va peut-être nous permettre de monter à
la draft
franchement je pense que c'est un truc
était parfaitement géré de la part de
deux trémies chan ok on va demander
d'ailleurs ce navire est respectivement
après thomas là dessus d'intéressants
tomate est adulte a déjà dû en parler
est ce que pour toi c'est win win ou est
ce que quand même passé à côté de dolci
chc c'est quand même bizarre non je
pense que c'est vraiment win win
très bon j'imagine qu'on va en parler
plus en détail mais je trouve ça très
intéressant d'avoir les pics 8es et 10
dans cette grave dans la mesure où j'ai
l'impression que derrière le top trois
il ya quand même pas mal de densité
entre 4 et 10 disons et que donc avoir
deux pics topten dans cette draft c'est
quand même nos dossiers d'autant plus
intéressant est pour moi pas persuadé
que ce soit vraiment ultra utile de
monter à la draft en parler plus en
détail on va en parler plus en détail
absolument donc les hawks ont les pics 8
10 17 35 41 44 et le numéro
complémentaire le six noms s'y pique
donc les hawks cette draft c'est
beaucoup est-ce que qu'est ce que tu as
entendu déjà qu'est ce qui se murmure
quels sont les rumeurs du côté des hawks
et lesquels on va garder les gars
lombard vendre lesquels on va s'attacher
lesquels on va à québec j'ai j'ai
entendu qu'on était assez agressif pour
essayer de monter à la draft
je vais écouter ce que vous disiez avec
avec les knicks
on aurait proposé du 8 et 10 pour
restituer leurs pick 3 bon clairement il
nous a envoyé bouler et apparemment on a
proposé à peu près la même chose pour le
pid 4d pelikan ce donc ça serait assez
récent genre dans les dernières heures
où les dernières 24 heures en tout cas
donc voilà je pense que je pense qu'il
ya du package qui v qui va être qu'il va
être fournie pour généralement quand on
fait ça c'est pour viser un joueur est
ce qu'il ya un nom qui ressort c'est
jared caliber c'est jade culver ressort
pas mal j'ai entendu aussi du hunter
bon même si je pense que c'est un peu
plus bas pour lui mais apparemment on
est très très chaud sur chaque éleveur
hunter qui pourrait être tout à fait
disponible en 8 si ça se trouve
si les choses si les dominos tombe du
bon côté on va dire donc donc 8 et 10
pour monter le 17 qui se sont lancés les
cours ont pour l on pourrait très bien
drafté ou alors on pourrait faire un
package aussi avec 8 et 17 pour être un
poil plus haut par en cinq ou six en
fait c'est il ya beaucoup d'inconnues
chez atlanta du fait du justement qu'il
tente de peak6 pic à la draft
c'est quand même un dixième de la draft
du cas chez nous tu viens chez nous
justement on va faire des package pour
pour libérer parce qu'on va pas
récupérer six joueurs c'est juste un
petit papa les articles oui surtout
quand on voit le tableau là il ya que
trois africaines c'est un effectif déjà
plutôt bien vous allez voir qu'ils
savaient peut-être non par contre pour
revenir vite fais ce que je veux sur ce
que vous disiez sur les knicks
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait ça pourrait
me paraître intéressant de filer un tour
de second tour un second tour pardon
pour ni lykina et le faire venir en back
up de triangle pour quand on a un gros
adversaire le foot en défense sur lui et
un peu le museler je pense que je pense
qu'il ya une complémentarité qui
pourrait être sympa en plus il aurait
pas tout le côté scoring parce qu'il y
aurait trahi hand il y aurait il y
aurait warter y aurait collins et
peut-être appris à de jeunes je sais pas
je pense que ça pourrait être
intéressant d'avoir un fils comme ça à
atlanta c'est pas lui c'est pas des
collants du tout comme manu tu valides
moi je suis moi j avais jamais pensé et
là d'un coup c'est vrai la lumière sur
l'aspect défensif c'est sûr que ça peut
être super intéressant après dans ce qui
est des matchs et que les hawks n'ont
pas ce que recherchent les cylons
horizon une chiée de laisser du
2e sambou 35 situe pas si tu package 41
44 pour thil et noir et puis moi pas sur
le papier oui c'est sûr que ça admettons
voulait gardiez c'est possible quand
même que vous drafté à huit et dix mois
c'est quelque chose qui a été possible
on nous pose la question qui qui alors
on dit du washington avec le pic 10 qui
elles sont les joueurs qui reviennent je
sais que vous avez work and énormément
de joueurs mais c'est marius les joueurs
de haut-rang two way le film sur les sur
les joueurs qu'on a qu'on a work out
après j'entends j'entends quand même pas
mal de chaussures comme on disait sur du
hunter sur du cam rédige je pense qu'on
est sur ce genre de profil
j'ai entendu aussi pas mal comme
poubelle chose sur beat à deux et en
dise et ça c'est pas mal du tout alors
je sais que notre ami antoine n'aime pas
trop parce que peut-être épouse coleen
ça fait un peu opération portes ouvertes
mais c'est le workout que vous avez 100
derniers mois j'avais toujours enfin on
en avait discuté un petit peu sur
twitter il y avait des jacks sonnailles
associe qui était beaucoup plus
défensive pour le coup et peut-être plus
complémentaire de police après j'ai
l'impression qu'il importe descendu en
termes de hype de notre côté ça reste un
joueur très jeune et j'ai l'impression
qu'ils entassent projette plus vers une
timeline de joueurs commençaient à ces
jeunes oui clairement
donc s'il n'est pas bon la l'année 1 je
veux dire c'est pas très grave
non ça nous permettra de re choper le le
furent speak l'année prochaine peut-être
manu qui est ce que tu aimes bien avec
les pics 8 et 10 à atlanta je ne sais
pas qui est ce que tu avais mis dans ta
mok moi je sais que je dois avoir eyes
et hunter ou eyes et rédige peut-être
mich et moi j'ai andrée hunter et clark
hunter éclats donc là en plus de
l'expérience du coup peut-être tu
aimerais bien c'est vrai que dit andrée
hunter à joris s'arrête nous si on se
trompe mais il ya un gros besoin d'un
défenseur sur les postes extérieurs camp
mais maintenant je vois pas du tout quoi
tu parles
enfin si tu avais le nombre de fois j'ai
désespéré où on met 125 points on en
prend 140 et c'est frustrant parce que
telle équipe qui tourne bien mais c'est
juste qu'ils sont incapables de faire un
stop ainsi par actuel est clairement
cette année mon jeu de la défense
convient montant et les gares ou sur les
coûts depuis
puis on y va quoi bon après y'a taurine
ce qui arrive est pas le plus mauvais
défenseur 1 il est reparti at il annoncé
partie et c'est alan craba oui du coup
c'est nul
ah oui pardon alors à la trappe pas trop
ben ben tu étais plutôt dans la veine
manu avec des dix joueurs qui apportent
vraiment de la défense diantre enter
brandon clark ou samia même chose d
assez facilement le trou laissé par
torres villa qui protège
il n'y a plus non se sont parlé l'année
dernière pour certains ça saigne
c'est un bus et c'est tout
all you can eat pour les médias braun
clark c'est une solution je sais pas si
c'est la solution autour d'eux
john collins passe quelque chose qu'on
les ait vraiment un trou noir défensif
je sais que les rucks beaucoup blake
clark
ils sont allés manger avec qui l'on est
et y ont fait beaucoup de blessés
emportés du pogo stick droit
je crois question lui donne absolument
oui c'est certain il a un potentiel
assez important manu c'est un joueur qui
a une mobilité pour sa taille assez
folle de jackson ne nous entend plus
ouais il ya de la friture sur la ligne
exactement au buffet des obsèques thomas
tu es toujours là
yes est ce que est ce que toi toi tout à
l'heure tu ne posais la question pour
toi il ya peu d'intérêt seuil est de
monter d'ailleurs on pose la question
sur le chat léon kilic et 10 contre le
pic des gaz et est ce que vous prenez
pour toi il ya pas trop de d'intérêt à
monter et tu garderait plus tôt 8 et 10
ben non parce que effectivement en fait
ça a intérêt à monter si tu arrives à
monter top 3 mais je pense pas qu'avec 8
et 10 et même si tu arrives à le faire
et quand tu as eu 8 et 10 je pense que
tu as disponibles les joueurs on a
besoin je ne sais pas si mon thé pour
avoir un darius garlande ou un cow-boy
surtout avec la perspective de
développement de rayons x est très utile
et par contre avoir un joueur type
cadres et dish all around poste 3 avec
le départ de taurian triste pour moi ça
fait beaucoup de sens et avoir un jour
du type de jackson heights
en complément de john collins dans un
profil de 5 plus défensif un peu même si
c'est pas mal et même si le jour mais ce
qu'a voulu faire chicago avec une jeune
raquette markkanen carter avec un profil
défensif qui qui qui contrecarre un
profil offensif
ça me paraît très pertinent donc pour
moi c'est ce qui fait le plus de sens et
après le petit 17 et il a peut-être un
peu moins d'utilité vu le nombre de
joueurs qui a de jeunes joueurs qui
atlanta et je pense que c'est une bonne
idée potentiellement aussi de le traiter
pour un pic de l'année prochaine et
l'année prochaine faire un gros push up
peut-être pour avoir un trait aux pics
de draft en accumulant un peu les assets
mais il est peut-être moins évident mais
effectivement le 8 et 10
moi je vois moins l'intérêt de monter
pour avoir garé dans le truc je risque
c'est que 8 8 et 10 culte ap un peu les
restes après mais reste de ce ce
troisième chapeau qu'on a qui va de
jarrett en gros c'est jared kamer
deviendront hunter cameron reggie
jackson ait daris garlande copyright et
après selon les uns et les autres
sékouba et après vous partez du principe
d'un échange avec les pics 8 et 10
mais il ya aussi d'autres choses qui
sont possibles pour avoir 1 8 et 17 1-17
voir un 10 et 35 41 par exemple qui
pourra nous permettre de monter je sais
pas par an de chez les cavs essayer de
choper 1,5 avec ce genre de chose quand
vous voyez ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'on n'est pas obligé d'avoir 8 et 10
qui partent ensemble est alors ben j'ai
une autre question pour toi dans la
foulée est ce que tu penses pas on a
parlé de gogh habitat t on a parlé de
brandon clark
hinse qui a pas un scénario dans lequel
il y en a un des deux qui tombe jusqu'au
oui
absolument il ya eu un scénario dans
lequel plus tôt mais oui moi je suis 100
pour sa tion si vous prenez les trois
choses mais je suis ça pour ça les
auditions
c'est à dire mettre mettre en
concurrence de deux joueurs tu devras
standiste et 17 pendant exactement
renvoyé à envoyer en termes de en terme
de défense faut pas oublier qu'on a
deadman qui était free agent qui
pourrait revenir et il a quand même fait
une société plus que correcte de ce côté
là en termes de protection de cercle ça
allait en plus ce qu'ils étaient ici
puisqu'il était capable de shoot à trois
points ce qui est vraiment très
intéressant pour nos arrières pour qu'il
puisse aller à rêver et d'étirer au
pourcentage
c'est peut-être plus un backup 6 10
peut-être peut-être après par rapport à
un rookie lequel tu fais passer devant
toi la question peut se poser je compte
dans le cadre d'un développement je
pense que tu mets le rookie et des
demandes en en back up met en place deux
petites choses l'autre jour john collins
est venu au nba crossover et j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir l'interviewer oui et
du coup je vais poser la question de la
défense parce que clairement ça me
travaillait trop et je lui dis enfin
voilà vous êtes l'une des pires défenses
de la ligue si ce n'est la pire de la
ligue
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire par
rapport à ça l'année prochaine et il m'a
dit ça va commencer par moi je vais
énormément travaillé cet été
de ce côté là sur mon explosivité sur
mon intelligence soit en termes de
placements etc
et deuxième chose je sais ce qu'il me
disait je pense qu'on n'a pas vu le
plein potentiel de
de lloyd pièce le coach d'atlanta et
puis il a eu assez peu de temps pour
pouvoir vraiment mettre des choses en
place et travailler une défense etc
il sait quelque chose qui devrait être
beaucoup travaillé cet été donc pour toi
peu drafté deux protecteurs de certes
c'est peut-être trop ce qu était en
transit à simple message je me dis que
tu me dis que ça peut être peut-être un
poil trop surtout sans racing deadman
derrière voilà je pense que ça ferait
peut-être doublons et peut-être avoir un
peu plus de créations en soit en sortie
de banc à l'intérieur ok dont joris
tonton scénario idéal pour pour le soir
de la draft
c'est pas facile quand on a ainsi pu
comme ça je m'expose un petit peu alors
tous les intervenants 41 à 44 pour le
corse pic
non non c'est vraiment très compliqué de
se dire ça très vilain qui a dit qu'il
prendrait le meilleur joueur disponible
et concrètement je pense que ça va
surtout dépendre des autres équipes
ce que laisse que les sept autres avant
vont pouvoir prendre et on va on va
faire par rapport à ça j'ai une pleine
confiance en très vif non plus j'aime
d'atlanta sortie pauline 117 119 et
webster en 19 pouces ix20 voilà il a dû
travailler son sujet il doit savoir oui
bref au td garden clairement et encore
une fois enfin on en revient ça mais par
rapport à l échange de triangle aussi il
s'est fait insulter par mois le premier
pendant et après la pré change au final
on se rend compte que c'était pas ceci
d'étonnant que ça te mettrais même loin
absolument joris il est l'heure on passe
aux lakers merci beaucoup de drogue avec
nous merci beaucoup monsieur on espère
qu'il sera avec nous demain en live
aussi pour la loterie soit beaucoup
parlé pour la porte pour la wii bon pour
la loterie de la drass pardon
mais la rente ben je crois que tu dois y
aller non ouais je vais à l'égard way
absolument sur le stream belle soirée
mais la belle midi plutôt benz canada
merci beaucoup
nous accueillons donc le représentant
des lakers je ne sais pas le cas il ya
du monde pour sa nation je sais pas qui
bonjour à toi
bonsoir un adrien dont exactement ça
adrien et les lakers france alors donc
vous avez pas de choix m'a plu plus on
va parler de ce trade quand même c'est
bien parce qu'on à thomas avec nous on a
manu aussi qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
tu en penses qu est ce qu est ce que tu
as une réaction à chaud différente que
celle que tu as maintenant en temps en
tant que fan est ce que c'est vous avez
trop d'onu ouais ça cela ça c'est une
chose pour moi sur laquelle j'ai encore
du mal a encore du mal à digérer et pour
tout te dire j'ai encore du mal à me
réjouir de à l'idée de se dire qu'on a
anthony davis dans le roster l'année
prochaine c'est con peut-être faire
paraître comme une sorte de problème de
riche mais je trouve qu'on est la
contrepartie était énorme et on a
vraiment hypothéqué non seulement le
roadster mais aussi le futur de l'équipe
pour une seule personne
alors certes c'est anthony davis mais
c'est très cher par rapport aux derniers
10 de superstars que l'on a vu dans la
ville quand on regarde ce qui est parti
en contre partie pour paul george qui
est parti pour butler ce qui est parti
pour pour recadrer léonarde qui avaient
tous un an de contrat ou pas beaucoup
plus c'est quand même énorme
on nous dit que c'est un super retraite
va demander l'avis thomas daum à qu'est
ce que tu en penses le qu'est ce que
t'en as pensé de ce trade et fait
effectivement je pense que ça fait que
ça fait beaucoup alors après pour un peu
entre balance c'est ton pessimiste je
pense que les traite que tu as cité
avant déjà c'était pour la plupart à
part que moi et pas des joueurs du
calibre d'anthony davis ce que soit le
type man butler est souvent la
contrepartie alors
qui avait pas autant de piques mais il y
avait dans le trade de kauai ya de
roseanne dans le trade de paul judge et
oladipo et c'est pas dit que il ya un
joueur de que vous ayez lâché qui est le
niveau de ces joueurs là qui sont
devenus alors là je presse je vais
parler avec le coeur mais je pense qu'il
ya déjà dans notre deal est déjà
meilleur que de rosen et ses débats
table sur la la force de paul george et
c'est aussi débat table sur la valeur à
l'époque du trail de dollars d'ipo
ok vous avez donné beaucoup mais c'est
enfin il n'y a pas un joueur
complètement capital dans ce que vous
avez donné et après pour moi je suis
aussi d'accord avec toi sur le fait que
vous avez donné beaucoup de toute façon
c'est ce que j'ai dit dans l'émission de
foster d'un clair il ya trois jours
après il faut beaucoup de si pour moi
pour que ce trait tourne très bien c'est
à dire s'il a maintenant vous allez
arriver à avoir un kemba walker et si
vous arrivez à avoir tous les meilleurs
pilotes et rendent la ligue type j'en
sais rien des wayne ellington derradji
bloc des vingt bref des joueurs en
minimes aux vétérans qui font vraiment
le taf
et si le coaching fonctionne bien comme
comme vous pouvez l'espérer là ça se
transformer en un bon trend mais
effectivement moi je pense que le plan à
de magic et d'europe et dinka qui était
faire développer des jeunes et un coach
au tour de lebron et attirer un gros
free agent cet été après avoir
potentiellement fait les play-offs est
cuit depuis depuis 4-5 mois et depuis ça
bah c'est un peu des alternatives plan b
qui vous coûte très cher qui vous oblige
à prendre beaucoup de risques voilà ça
c'est un peu mon point de vue sur ce sur
ce trend est bien
une réaction peut-être le cosby depuis
le début pelinka et magic avait dit que
de toute façon pour gagner un titre dans
cette ligue il fallait absolument de
superstar savait qu'ils allaient faire
j'aimerais d'ailleurs
oui on peut les battre après bas par
rapport aux raptors
a priori je sais pas comment on peut
apprécier le titre des raptors mais pas
moyen de super ça et après sur la
troisième oui il ya beaucoup de si et
c'est vrai que déjà beaucoup si le
premier 6 et quel sera notre enveloppe
réel de recrutement sachant qu'elle peut
aussi entre 23 millions et 32 millions
et quelque pour un teint pour un autre
max lot ça va quand même conditionné pas
mal le roster et après la valeur
sportive et ce sur quoi pourra
travailler vos galles et son coaching
staff c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup si
et beaucoup d'incertitudes pour ça que
je te dis qu'à l'heure actuelle je
digère moi je digère qu'aujourd'hui on
dirait un peu en europe un roster
famélique je sais même pas si on va
réussir a dit les puisque c'est ce qui
est un peu dans l'air du temps dit dès
maintenant c'est de l'envoyer ailleurs
wagner bon gars et johnny oui donc à
voir comme ça c'est assez incroyable
face au recul visiblement le trade a été
fait sans vraiment de visibilité sur ce
que sera le cap ensuite compte la
cervelle situations d'urgence ça c'est
typique de ça c'est typiquement la
compétence de pelinka de pékin qui
s'écoute que lui et tout seul ou qu'ils
écoutent remli ce qui est maintenant le
président de l'ombre dans chez les
lakers
donc oui alors je sais pas qu'il a
autour si les écoute aussi ne les écoute
pas à mon avis doit pas écouter grand
monde puisque on sait par exemple pour
revenir à la draft de l'an passé le
scouting département des lakers
et comme pour moi à mon sens un réputé
pour sa grande compétence avait choisi
avec le pic 27 au mari dans pardon 25
omari spelman
et magic et pink a été dans une autre
pièce et ils ont décidé de prendre
wagner parce que c'était leur choix à
eux sans écouter donc le reste de
l'équipe iv à vi année sur ça tu vois
sur le fait de ne pas prendre en
considération le salary cap ça ne
m'étonnerait pas donc ça n'aurait pas
forcément été bien avec avec le 4s que
tu avais commencé à regarder
ah oui j'avais j'avais ciblé en fait
j'ai même écrit un article pour que
basket
à ce sujet la démo pour moi c'était une
bataille entre éleveurs et et hunter par
rapport aux besoins de l'équipe et
j'avais une préférence pour pouvoir être
calvaire on m'a dit beaucoup de monde
mais comment ne pas avoir de préférence
après direct calvaire c'est vrai qu'il
s'est un petit peu tout faire là thomas
ou manu tiens manuge et hésitez pas à
demander ton avis sur ce trade c'est que
moi en tout cas ce qui m'a le plus
chagriné c'est que c'est que je charte
ne joue pas le titre dès l'année
prochaine
après moi je trouve aussi que sont
beaucoup trop donné quoi 3,3 premier
tour on se rend compte puisqu'on ont
donc potentiellement en 2022 ou annonce
un swap en 2022 non c'est entre les deux
c'est un swapo 2021 2022 qui est on le
rappelle une nouvelle fois pro très
probablement la draft school servir la
double draft on prendra les joueurs qui
sortent de la foule et les joueurs qui
sans leur première année une scie et
parce que ce devrait être la fin de de
l'homme du passage obligatoire par la
salle et se disait ben sur notre chat à
nous c'est que là les clubs les coeurs
viennent de lâcher septembre en un coup
ouais ce qui est quand même assez
immense et là tu te retrouves avec ma
plus rien anthony davis quand même là
ils ont deux joueurs en fait plus ou
moins potable ils ont quelque chose là
aussi
parmi les tiennent peut-être trop et
alors est ce que tu as des idées est ce
que tu penses qu'ils vont parce que là
ils vont vendre
donc ils vont vendre des joueurs contre
deux pour faire de la masse de l'espace
salariés m c'est ça oui c'est le plan et
alors moi déjà ça me semble un petit peu
aberrant je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez de se dire que on va devoir je
sais pas contre tu vois si on doit trade
wagner j'ose espérer qu'on va pas encore
rajouter du pic pour envoyer wagner
autre part d'un monde pur et parfait tu
dois récupérer une petite contrepartie
pour lui même pour bon gars même si
c'était si c'est des droits pour un
joueur qui mettra jamais les pieds en
nba n'a récupéré un des trois comme ça
dans le passé mais on doit pas à nouveau
se dépouiller pour récupérer quelque
chose que tu va vouloir balancer des
derrière pour faire du cap spahic
supplémentaires mais en même temps ça
pour arriver parce qu'en ce moment on
très très très mal enfin si tu es l'un
des défauts de paiement cas c'est qu'il
a il donne vraiment zéro valeur aux
jeunes du moins ils n'arrivent pas à
capitaliser sur sur la valeur pour en
tirer quelque chose de cohérent pour lui
il veut quelque chose qui dont il
connaît la valeur et oui tu vois par
exemple quand il envoie mirail book
à contre bloc pour me suffire c'est un
jeune contre un vétéran quand on connaît
les qualités et les défauts et pourquoi
rajouter un deuxième tour de draft
ça c'est un truc je comprends pas
doit-il est également pour nous ce cas
là avec les clippers ok c'est très bien
bon on en voit habillé est ok c'est
cohérent mais pourquoi tu dois rajouter
ou bats tu vois quelque chose on tousse
ou les clips et les clippers attendais
pas c'est ce qui me fait un petit peu
peur sur les négociations qui risquent
d'arriver de m'asseoir et est donc la
tâche est encore en plus c'est ça parce
que donc les lakers vont quand même être
active demain soir au delà de du fait de
deux décès de faire de la masse de
l'espace salariale par michael bay est
ce qu'il ya eu des rumeurs comme quoi il
allait chasser du ca pas filtré sap a
filtré après je t'avoue que au niveau
des insiders niveau des lakers
et contrairement aux années précédentes
ça n'a pas trop trop suivi ce qui se
passait pour l'épauler joueurs je parle
même pas du premier tour mais même sur
le second tour où les où le scouting
départementale habitudes comme de faire
venir des palanquées le joueur pour tous
pour tous les tester cette année ça n'a
pas été trop trop couvert donc à mon
avis si pourtant ça serait logique je
serais d'accord pour se dire bon tu
recrutes aller times a acheté un voire
deux pics ou adil est pour pour deux
pics du second tour que tu signera après
avec la bayanne eu mal par exemple mance
pas eu assez pour être cohérent mais on
a vraiment zéro idées sur si on va le
faire dans quelle reine l'on pourrait le
faire et donc quelles seraient les
cibles
après je t'avoue que si ça se fait je
fais confiance à notre scouting staff
très bien oui c'est au moins quelque
chose que vous avez c'est le dernier
département sein de cette franchise
merci d'avoir été avec nous adrillon
sept derniers matches de ligue 1 n'avait
pas de nom n'est pas très intéressant
c'est ça merci beaucoup merci bien
beaucoup l'analyse et à la prochaine
on accueille on accueille le responsable
du compte twitter des 400 france cap
ferrat ça c'est ce que vous entendez
bien on entend parfaitement c'est
antoine aussi c'est juste oui tout plein
d'antoine en l'absence d'une autre
je vais élever oui non rien je vais
mettre là pendant que tu nous racontes
un petit peu l'état des finances à
cleveland les rumeurs qui arrivent pour
ce qui pourrait se passer demain soir je
vais je vais mettre là la page que tu
nous a concocté pour le site en arrière
plan pour les gens du live
vas-y on t'écoute alors pour cet été
c'est très compliqué l'état de nos
finances très compliqué c'est encore
sympa parce qu'on a déjà
134 millions de garanties oui à peu près
à peu près tous les joueurs qu'on avait
l'année passée sont garantis à part
marquer ce christ je doute qu'on lui
redonne un contrat
channing frye qui va partir à la
retraite david noah bas que moi je
garderai bien je pense qu'il pourrait
avoir un meilleur contrat et une
meilleure situation ailleurs qu'après
après c'est tout en fait tous les autres
encore sous contrat on a signé l'été
passé kevin love pour environ 120
millions sur quatre ans et pour être
bien complet sur les finances alors cet
été c'est très compliqué mais vaut
savoir que c'est la dernière année de
contrat pour la free agency 2020
tristane thompson 20 millions sera plus
sous contrat joe smith mais on en
reparlera sûrement plus tard dans les
rumeurs mais il sera plus là de toute
façon
brandon knight 15 millions ce sera aussi
la fin de son contrat
jordan clarkson 13 millions aussi la fin
de son contrat
bref pour la free agency 2020
actuellement on n'a que 51 millions de
garantie même pas garantie on a ce 42
millions de garanties sur un gros que
deux joueurs larry nance des cabines au
bond donc c'est comme un peu comme les
knicks en parler à leurs une feuille
blanche à partir de l'été prochain à
sortir l'été prochain et du coup cet été
c'est quoi on va pas est-ce que ça sert
vraiment à quelque chose de dégraisser
maintenant alors que dans un an ce sera
assez simple c'est pas le but
tous les contrats pourri qu'on a pris
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup qui ont mal
analysé nos transferts de cet été de cet
été de cette saison quand on a repris
brandon knight qu'on a pris johnson en a
pris et dellavedova j'ai oublié de citer
qui sera aussi en fin de contrat
marquise crise c'était que des contrats
dits pour y est vraiment pourri mais
grâce à ça et autres et qu'on a fait
cette année on a récupéré deux forces 30
pique donc celui de houston de cette
année est celui de 2000 ou qui en 2021
où il y en a aussi récupéré six secondes
seconde au second tour
pendant qu'en c'est tout ce qu'on a
dilapidé ces dernières années pour faire
un effectif cohérent pour lebron james
ça fait du bien de les récupérer donc
cet été six joueurs là ils vont pas
partir déjà 1 parce que à la limite
tristone thomson peut servir dans un
équipe nous une équipe qui a vraiment
besoin d'un pivot mais même pour 18
millions il faudra reprendre un contrat
pour y en face mais les autres qui va
mettre 15 millions pour prendre de night
13 millions pour clarkson peut-être on
n'a aucun intérêt
il a fait plus ou moins deux bonnes
saisons dans son style dans les autres
ils seront là cette année ou non sont
tous à cette année bon donc parlons
draft par l'ondraf clip simple et pique
26 communes allemandes eu de choix pour
vos premiers tours qu'est ce que tu as
entendu déjà au niveau des rumeurs est
ce que tu as les faits car enseigner
cela défavorise que dans les questions
sur certains joueurs
j'ai un peu peur parce que bon déjà je
l'avais très mauvaise mois le joueur que
je voulais à tout prix comparé à
beaucoup de monde s'était pas et ian
milham sonne mais cette terre bar est
bon il sera certainement plus sain qui
sera de toute façon plus là et après
donc avec le pic 5
depuis depuis la loterie en hausse
jusqu'à il ya quelques jours c'était
jared culver et ça se jouait un peu pour
certains insider y avait un doute et que
dire de hunter il ya eu cambridge qui a
eu une réunion cette semaine aux fins de
semaines passées chez certains jours
mais vu qu'il s'était opérée sauf erreur
donc il peut ne pas voir comme il n'a
pas exactement
donc comme je l'aï dit quand il ya eu la
loterie sur twitter oise moi j'ai une
préférence
comme beaucoup de monde comme j'ai pu
l'entendre plutôt dans le podcast pour
retirer de culver
j'ai vraiment peur qu'avec le pic quatre
quais qui a été transféré des lakers
qu'il soit aussi lui plus disponible et
oui c'est possible
après j'avais dit que culver hunter
aurait dit mireille lors de juste le
temps en ailier quoi exactement juste
après la loterie et mais j'ai quand même
2,3 doute après vous connaissez beaucoup
plus que moi d andrée watters je pense
que ça peut être un très bon joueur mais
je doute un peu de son son plafond je
vois comme un excellent défenseur mais
mu
quand je vois certaines comparaisons
avec paul george moi je vois pas tout à
fait la même chose
après je suis pas un expert comme voix
sur les points sont là où la manu qu'est
ce que tu peux dire sur 10 andreu auteur
je pense que ce que l'analyse d'antoine
sur le plafond pas forcément où est pas
mauvaise
donc par contre c'est papa de georges
frêche est pas où tu as vu ça oui oui
j'ai vu ça dans plus dans le type de
joueur défenseur qui peut mettre 3 et
qui au début de sa carrière aura de la
peine à la création
après
oui c'est ça ils m'apprennent chercher
plus de choix toi moi je vois plus de
peau de george à part le tir dont qui a
travaillé dans jarhead culver que dans
l'ordre hunter et gagne plus grand
ensemble
enfin plus étoffée peut-être pas plus
grande est au fait que j'arrive à 15 ans
manu vase il poursuit sur sur un auteur
ou à mantes ermont et à cergy qui me
fait penser un peu amicale bris 10 c'est
un joueur qui qui va être fait pour une
équipe qui doit gagner maintenant en
fait comme nombreux mois qu'as tu as
forcément mais comme commandes à une
10ème place très haut et très haut même
si je pense qu'il y en a encore sous la
[ __ ]
parce que notamment en entamant ou tiers
oui peut qu'y pas encore s'améliorer
même s'il a dû 40 quasiment 44% à 37
années c'est ça mais j'ai eu pour moi il
a il peut encore s'améliorer dans le tir
sur certains aspects notamment la
rapidité puisque le tir voter c'est un
tour il avait il y avait peut-être plus
de temps pour armer cette année vu qu'il
est grand plus avec ses longs bras de
même à tisser merci je trouve qu'il
n'était pas forcément
allez-y libre bien meilleur dans le
catch and shoot et dans quelle en secret
son tir notamment à trois temps oui pour
l'instant il peut se créer à mi distance
ouais voilà c'est pour ça que j'ai un
peu de talent avec
bon après on en reparlera plus tard
s'ils le prennent comparé à nos joueurs
que je vais parler juste après ça me va
très bien quand même
mais si d andré auteur arrive dans une
équipe où on a comme seul créateur et je
mets des normes guillemets dessus que
c'est pas des créateurs des postes 1 où
ces collines sexton qui même s'ils
méritent pas tout la déferlante de haine
qu'il a eu surtout une fin d'année très
prometteuse mais qui en tout cas pas un
créateur à côté de lui en fin d'année il
y avait brandon knight au niveau
création n'est pas aussi et puis on
arrose man qui crée un petit peu depuis
depuis la halle mais sinon on n'a pas
deux créateurs on à kevin love qui est
capable de faire deux trois passes mais
c'est pareil au kitsch et puis on a des
pivots qui sont et puis valenciennes
tutoré bauer comme tristan thompson
moses itx qui lui est plus doyen un peu
plus technique mais quand même dans le
style et leur bourreau de luxe gloire à
cannes
donc s'ils arrivent à cleveland
même si je sais que le tout nouveau
coach et avec des déclarations sur le
col était fan de denver qui est john
payne qui est un homme qui connaît bien
la laïcité
il y connaît assez bien mais j'ai peur
qu'ils tombent dans le pire
environnement possible de toutes les
équipes qui a entre les places qui va
tomber entre 4 et 8 à mon avis ou encore
peut-être les bourses où c'est encore
pire ce qui ôte aux porteurs de vent
mais j'ai peur qu'ils tombent dans la
pire place possible on a pas de création
et on n'a pas trop de talent autour
fort collins texte n'était qu'à 19 de
vrais talents
donc il risque d'être très vite dans la
lumière est peut-être trop tôt dans la
lumière c'est intéressant on va demander
son avis à thomas et ce côté du partage
l'analyse de notre ami des câbles est ce
que pour toi il faut quelqu'un qui
transcendant petit que l'équipe est qui
et qui puisse créer pas seulement et pas
uniquement quelqu'un qui soit une espèce
de 3e ou 4e couteau je pense que dans la
situation des caves où il faut quand
même multiplié le talent certes il y
manque de création mais en fait il
manque un
tout dans cette équipe la moins une idée
mais après vous si de me dire ce que
vous en pensez je me dis qu'avec le pic
cinq sites à des équipes qui cherchent à
monter à la draft est ce que t'as pas
envie d'échanger potentiellement le 5 et
le 26 contre typiquement on a parlé tout
à l'heure du 8 et 10 d'atlanta si jamais
ils veulent absolument deux montées en
cinq
ce que j'ai pas l'impression que ce soit
que leveurs enter kobe white ou etc
ce soit forcément le futur frontside
player de de cleveland
par contre multiplier des talents autour
d'eux des loteries pic type des calmes
rédige des ou des joueurs un peu un peu
derrière des jackson heights on a parlé
tout à l'heure c'est koudougou yahoo des
joueurs comme ça est-ce que c'est t'as
pas envie de multiplier un peu d des
joueurs comme ça plutôt que de focus et
sur un manque de l'équipe ou un joueur
mais surtout qu'aux places 1k a priori
battue va pas enfin fatalement changer
ta franchise du jour au lendemain avec
ça c'est quelque chose qui revenait pas
mal dans le chatt base yang wang
qu'est ce que tu penses il ya pas mal de
rumeurs beaucoup à 400 justement qui
voudraient nous nous refiler deux pics
pour prendre notre place en cinq mois ci
nous donne le 8 et le 10 comme ça dit le
triple a donnée avant 8 et 10 contre 5
et 26 ça me va très bien
parce que surtout c'est dire est que le
beurre moi j'ai peur mais je pense
vraiment qu'il va être pris en 4 ou et
les options qui a précédé deux auteurs
que j'ai dit je suis pas convaincu après
il ya un énorme dérive car land ces
derniers jours à cleveland vous avoue
j'arrive pas à le comprendre parce que
on a collé une secte en un les deux
peuvent pas jouer en même temps sur le
terrain parce qu'en défense déjà qu'on a
des passoires derrière donc on était la
pire défensive
là le pire défensive writing de
l'histoire cette année sur un jeu de
guerre lors de postes de leurs ventes
ont explosé les acteurs même si je tombe
de tous ceux en dessous du top 3 je
pensais le jour qu'elle met
après après en huit sites à 8 10
véhicules camry 10 ch et c'est compliqué
notre notre équipe c'est compliqué parce
qu'on a on a des joueurs un peu partout
il ya beaucoup de rumeurs quand même
aujourd'hui on peut pas tellement
prendre un poste 4 parce qu'on a quand
même les deux seuls joueurs qui sont là
sur le long terme compte actuellement
séquelles alors encore une fois dans la
situation de cleveland le joueur qui
sera pris sera probablement le joueur le
plus haut sur le board sans surprendre
mais sans prendre en compte propre en
poste 4 et puis qu'il est derrière qui a
villeneuve et la rina des seniors
actuellement dans la rotation qui en
plus les deux on est peut-être les deux
meilleurs joueurs actuels savatan mais
je dis pas que c'est simple en mêlant
plus les postes 4 ans n'ira pas non plus
n'a pas tous les mois je serai assez de
6 à 8 et 10 oui la rumeur que atlanta
voudrait donner que 10 et 17 là ça
m'intéresse beaucoup moins ou après que
sous le dire il n'y a pas de rumeurs de
love qui depuis windhorst je crois que
la sortie ça hier comme quoi il y avait
eu énormément de discussions ces
derniers jours avec kevin love pour être
changé et que c'était un peu compliqué
de trouver la bonne contrepartie
oui mais qu actuellement c'était du
50-50 pour qu'il reste ou parte lors de
lors de la draft alors d'assurer de la
draft et je pense que ça peut être un
joueur je vois pas l'intérêt c'est
discutable quand je vois le la page que
tu affiches sur youtube
tu vois en 6 les phénix qui a besoin
d'un poste 4 oui pourrait les intéresser
c'est quand même or elle est et il a été
blessé cette année mais ça a été un
blessé grave
il ya eu quand même eu depuis janvier il
a quasiment pas joué alors qu'il aurait
pu jouer way we été préservés lui
risques de sautes de dire il ya quand
même une chance sur deux appuis à mon
avis ça il ya quand même plus en plus de
bruit chez les insiders
commence à essayer de le bouger il a un
contrat qui est très élevé mais avec une
augmentation du kaki 30000 bon 28 cette
année trente l'année d'après 30 l'année
d'après il retombe à 28 la 4e année qui
est encore correcte rangs un joueur qui
peut le faire du 20 10 et il ya encore
un autre joueur qui va susciter de
l'intérêt mais pas pour la même raison
lors de la draft cette jr smith
oui c'est en parle dans le chat aussi un
contrat qui est jeu 15 millions soit 15
6 millions mais il en a que 3 de
garantie donc ça peut aller intéresser
une équipe qui les équipes comme je vois
l'avait dégraisser peut-être si tu
propose par exemple aux hits pour le
sahara est d'un peu haut mais pour le
13e choix on leur propose
on leur prend un contrat qui veulent
plus ils ont tellement plus leur pic 13
contre notre pic 26 et jr smith et pique
quand même et il économise environ 12
millions de ouais ouais il ya des corps
ya des candidats ans qu'on disait tout à
l'heure
boule lyonnaise hit pistols même les
heures effectivement peut-être il
pourrait être intéressant mais c'est
pour ça que c'est assez difficile à lire
parce que apport actuellement j'allais
peut-être même plus il ya peut-être que
sexton qui est garantie d'être là mais
vu la hype garlande qui a vraiment
augmenté ces derniers jours à cleveland
je me demande si même sexton a pas il
n'est pas n'est pas à vendre sous le
manteau parce que je pense que si moi je
suis capable depuis mon bureau de voir
que sexton et garonne ont jamais joué
ensemble
je pense bien que le board et en plus le
staff du clip anti s'est nettement
amélioré cet été est capable de le voir
manu qui est ce que tu devras ferait en
4 puisque
justement antoine disait garland
calvaire sera certainement partie ce que
toi tu si c'était toi le gm des pélicans
sud resterait 15h04 ouais je pense que
c'est ce qui leur convient mais moi
j'aime bien le fit avec une guirlande
étonnamment extend la roquette à peu
veut surtout offensivement ensemble
alors c'est défensivement c'est parce qu
après si tu te vendent notre calvaire
il ya en valeur je pense que c'est
beaucoup puissent un jour qu'un peu
polyvalent en plus qui pourra jouer le 3
4 ou et éleveurs il peut défendre
peut-être sur détroit des petits 4 les
tout-petits 4 et bah ouais c'est de la
défense et attaque il est assez
polyvalent donc ça c'est une arme qui
luttera très demandé dans la nba
d'aujourd'hui après ans moi je pense
qu'il va partir au pélican sauf si la
chaussure clic
après il y a toujours la possibilité qui
est une équipe qui tombe amoureuse de
gars langue de cameron rédige et qui
achètent le pic des pelikan ce qui je
pense est à vendre
vous voyez eu des rumeurs comme quoi les
changer eux-mêmes décembre il ya
beaucoup d' équipes qui veulent
descendre
donc c'est donc pour toi le scénario
antoine si situe éleveurs aient pas pris
en 4 comprend que le beurre et où on
reste comme ça et sinon on essaye de
trade armes c'est ça alors bon scénario
idéal pour la draft idéal oui on échange
kevin love contre contre le 6 par
exemple pour un picto 10 on descend avec
notre sac est que là on pourrait prendre
le 10 et le 17 par exemple ouais et avec
le 26 parce qu'on n'a pas parlé moi je
très intriguée par oc pas là d'accord
j'ai vraiment intéressant à cleveland
après ce projet à opale mais après il ya
aussi beau le bol qui chutent énormément
dans la draft où il était annoncé
top 5 avant sa blessure après top 10 top
15 mais là maintenant il est top 20 ou
plus bas pour certains et pour certains
spécialistes de labarthe donc intéressés
mais je pense que toi sans kevin love y
sert à rien à cleveland il va gâcher ces
années c'était l'année et il va être
quand même même cette année ça va être
on va être une des pires équipes de la
ligue 1 ouais encore une fois même si je
pense qu'on va faire bien mieux parce
que on a quand même fait cette année
sans la moitié de nos titulaires toute
l'année et puis l'année prochaine c'est
pas dit qu'on arrive à signer ce ne sera
pas une grosse année au niveau de la tri
agency le sauf s'il ya beaucoup de
joueurs qui signent des contrats non
donc il y aura de l'argent mais pas
forcément de joueurs qui vont nous faire
passer un cap
donc les pics cleveland s'est pas à los
angeles ou new york à un ring
tiers-monde
donc ouais mais multiplié le plus
possible de de potentiel en potentiel
par contre si on n'arrive pas à trade et
kevin love contrer notre pic 5 plus bas
oui mais qu'on garde quand même un pic
même s'ils ont échangé avec les héros
garder un pic dans le top 10 dans le top
ouais là je vois j'ai votre autre mot
qui draft dans les yeux en vite s'il ya
ka murray dit shaw en oeuvre ses coûts
dont mme bouille à ça ça me va bien
mais après tout la toute la partie
pendant donne clark non merci
jackson a convaincu qu' une pour moi il
ya il est autant aux parce que c'est le
seul pivot c'est vrai ils profitent de
la prime à ce qu'ils disent car city les
spécialistes
non d'après attend ça s'il ya énormément
de potentiel de potentiel relevé ouais
bien sûr
mu tout à fait ce qu'on a dit et répété
toute l'année même même calvaire
finalement
l'utilité première option c'était passe
pas très bien passé cette année donc
énormément deux troisièmes couteaux
potentiel et ensuite de role players de
vraiment potentiel star basse le tome 3
parce que oui et encore oui la voix mais
pris à des joueurs plus bas comme qui
m'intrigue comme langford porter juniors
ont une portée générale nassir lyttle
qu'elle donne johnson je suis pas du
tout convaincu pas chez moi mais bon ça
c'est personnel des joueurs comme même
bol ball comme j'ai dit ça vaut que par
là moi qui m'intéresse beaucoup
il ya quand même il ya une flopée de
joueurs qui seront intéressants mais je
pense la draft sur le top 5 est plus
faible que l'an passé c'est certain à
faire c'est finalement c'est pas si rare
que ça d'avoir ont juste un ou deux
joueurs au top et le reste il faut
savoir faire des bunkers au bon endroit
pour finir vas-y vas-y
j'espère juste qu'on va pas qu'on va pas
faire du statu quo j'espère vraiment
qu'on va bouger pendant cette draft
déjà parce qu'on a besoin un peu
d'animation à cleveland et cissé en 5
pour prendre du d'heyrieux garlande ou
du copyright
parce que unis sont assez aux communes a
été rude aussi été mentionné à cleveland
mais jusqu'où on en parle je comprends
pas ce qui arrive ce qui met avec sexton
passe défensivement c'est injouable
c'est largement pire que quand petit
gars ma colonne qui sont pourtant
peut-être backup défensif le plus faible
la ligne donc qui bouge qui faste qui
fasse sauter les seules pièces de valeur
qu on a 300 qui est là il faut il faut
il faut construire donc autant autant
casser les murs en plus à un coach qui
aime les jeunes autant prenez des
risques quoi j'ai bien très bien et là
je te remercie d'avoir été avec nous
antoine merci pour ton analyse et à
demain ce sera compliqué mais
pour le pic saint louis allez pour le
fixer un coup oui on fait comme ça merci
beaucoup
bonne soirée et manu avant qu alors on
va d'abord accueillir notre ami des
wizards qui est un peu patienter on a
pris un peu de retard sur les cav's
comment vas tu donc ça va un jour ça va
bien est ce que tu peux me donner ton
prénom je trouve alors moi c'est bizarre
les mais vous pouvez dire berne ne sera
plus rapide à baives ok on va t'appeler
belle avant avant de donner la parole
mais manu il ya une demande pourquoi
dans le chat il ya un malade qui
demandent pourquoi camaret dichy les
aussi bas alors je te laisse répondre
bâti plus bas ça fait chaud et assez
décevante
je pense qu'il ya de ça il ya je pense
qu'il est aussi une question de mental
j'ai passé stop psychologique devant moi
mais paul toutefois demandé antoine mais
je pense qu'il ya de ça et peut-être une
inquiétude sur son source nous tire
aussi il a montré plus jeunes qu'ils
pouvaient tirer mais cette saison ça a
été catastrophique
qu'est ce que c'est un mauvais
environnement le fait d'être entouré de
deux monstres et continue à lui s'est
pas retrouvé dans un rôle dans laquelle
il attendait c'est c'est possible aussi
après on peut très bas il a annoncé ba
mais peut-être de kata kata 9,4 à 8,1
donc au final c'est pas là beaucoup de
joueurs qui qu'on serait là où ça peut
faire vraiment sainte avertir et selon
les fuites et les envies du dg m coach
ça peut vraiment vraiment changé donc
moi je ne trouve pas si bas je pense que
tu de son règne il y en a qui le voit
descendre peut-être un peu plus mais
dans ce cas là il faudrait qu'ils aient
un jackson highway aussi dessin une
surprise dans le tournoi ou un sac ou
d'ailleurs chose que je faisais en
décembre
même moi c'est un joueur qui va dans
lequel va on y croire je sais pas
pourquoi
du coup
1 whissell ces messages le talent ça
ouaip il a de la confiance en lui il a
montré sur certains matches ou moche au
tir il n'a pas perdu confiance dans son
tir est si bas c'est l'instinct du fin
c'est la mentalité du twitter qu'il va
vraiment il va continuer a ajouté ça
rentrera forcément un jour c est rentré
contre florida state au buzzer il a fait
deux énormes matches contre contre
virginia ou choot donc il est capable de
tout et non pas de souci là-dessus je
pense qu'ils crolles ii un peu l'image
d'un ses coups francs de choyer faut
vraiment lui montrer qu on l aime
il tenait de la meilleure chance en lui
qui compte dans la rotation qui est chez
nous et je t'ai ce que pour moi il n'est
pas si bas que ça c'est sûr on
l'attendait par ses complices à peu près
son règne actuellement non n'attendez
pas de gêne en rien que si on attendait
pas que le verrou kobe white on
attendait pas aussi bon c'est vrai que
c'est un peu destinée comme ça du fait
de la saison était en fait au fil de la
saison
s'il y en a qui montre comment il va qui
descendront peut-être qu'ici il aurait
été je ne sais pas moi aoua touré qui
sera numéro deux c'est vrai c'est vrai
bon voilà en tout cas une réponse
complète pour arabe dans le tchat
c'est l'heure de baives c'est l'heure
des wizards on regarde le tableau là il
ya plein de restrictive c'est à 100 ou
de tin option 2 une intersaison hyper fo
chez moi c'est hyper fou parce que déjà
on n'a pas de general manager c'est un
peu embêtant
à la veille de la draft donc pour le
moment c'est l'assistant de de cranfield
qui prend le relais qui je pense sera
confirmée puisque toutes les pistes sont
à explorer ne mène nulle part
oui la cei ou jerry ne pas venir masai
ujiri veut pas venir le john zeng
a refusé donc je pense que il va être
concerne à ce poste-là
et du coup le choix neuf va répondre à
beaucoup de questions sur notre free
agency énormément de joueurs sont
restrictives d'autres ondes et des
options joueurs donc est-ce qu'on va
prendre plutôt un meneur arrière est ce
qu'on va plutôt prendre à l'intérieur
donc il ya pas mal de questions qui se
posent sachant que déjà sur johnny les
bras des villes tu as à peu près 80
millions déjà du capot puisque wall e
passe à son super max de l'année
prochaine donc c'est assez compliqué
donc il ya plusieurs solutions qui sont
quand même potentiel un trait de john
wall on traite de brad débile pour
essayer d'attraper un pic plus haut dans
la draft tout en essayant de conserver
notre pic 9 pour essayer de construire
quelque chose avec des jeunes c'est
c'est assez compliqué de se projeter
tant qu'il n'y a pas vraiment de de
bondir de gm devienne d'autre chose sûre
parce que on n'a pas de gm
s'il faut le nouveau gène ne va même pas
garder scott brooks
donc est ce que ça vaut le coup d'écouté
scott brooks pour choisir quelqu'un s'il
faut il sera même pas là pour coacher
l'équipe face et c'est compliqué de se
projeter dans une équipe avec un front
office ou siffler ou quoi alors il ya
une chose de sûre belle vous avez le
petit 9 je suis là l'air
qu'est ce que toi tu aimerais en fer de
7,9 quel profil de joueur tu aimerais tu
aimerais avoir sachant qu encore une
fois dans la situation du blizzard sera
probablement meilleurs talents
disponibles
je pense que six meilleurs talents
disponibles il faut les chercher
ready ou kobe white ci soit s'ils sont
hors la loi s'ils sont encore là ou
sinon ça sera ndoumbé yahoo
l'index wade parce que les incertitudes
autour du cas de mahinmi et surtout ne
contractent pas demandé les tomates
bryant sont assez compliqué donc il faut
anticiper sur toutes les lignes
et c'est de voir qu'est ce que
concrètement qu'on peut faire est-ce
qu'on va concerner brillante à quel prix
sera conservé
un torrent skip toujours pareil à quel
prix c'est assez compliqué donc voilà
faire prendre le meilleur disponible
mais je pense qu'il faudrait mieux
choisir sur les lignes arrière plutôt
qu'à l'intérieur de l'intérieur une
analyse partagée par par thomas est
encore là je crois yes alors bien sûr
les lignes je suis d'accord en fait pour
moi même plus que le jam pour moi la
grosse discussion ça va être au tour de
brad les bills est ce qui est un peu
horrible pour les wizards dans cette
draft je trouve c'est que s'il garde la
deûle et bill moi je les vois bien et
que soit un post 3 types cam rédige un
peu complet all around parce qu'il
voulait faire de d'auto porter mais qui
à mon avis sera parti soit
éventuellement un poste 4 qui joue au
large tout pour compenser un peu d'aidé
profil défensif qu'ils ont au pivot si
awards revient un jour et des andes
renders à mon avis sera parti aussi donc
je pense que c'est un peu compliqué s'il
trade bill je vois bien un joueur comme
jared culver arrivé plus tôt balles
courtes effectivement à ce moment là où
ce sera besoin où ils auront besoin mais
ce pic neuf pour moi pour les wizards et
répondent à aucune de leurs aucun de
leurs besoins alors oui peut-être qu'ils
vont se retrouver à draft et 1c
koudougou ya mais je pense qu'il ya une
réflexion quand même à avoir autour de
l'avenir de bradley bill dans une équipe
qui a été très décevant de cette année
qu aura pas de jeunots de l'année
prochaine est ce que est ce que ça vaut
le coup de garder bradley bilou est ce
que il partirait pas sûr rebuilt complet
et à ce moment là s'il ya transfert de
billy enfin il ya ce sera forcément
contre des très hauts pics et et le pic
9 dépendra aussi de ce qu'ils auront
draft et potentiellement à avoir et ce
qu'il faut faire table rase ben il faut
il faut faire il faut faire quelque
chose c'est sûr il faut reconstruire
c'est sûr après maintenant il faut faire
un choix ce sera soit john-molson droit
débile népal et de quoi est ce que ça
vaut peut-être pas le coup ont connu
tous john roll ça
valeur est ce que ça vaut pas le coup
d'aller chercher une équipe en quête
d'un meneur qui pourra peut-être se
passer pendant un arm du type d'être le
magic ou peut-être phénix qui hissa
dérangera pas d'avoir le jeune homme
blessé pendant énorme
ils savent ce que c'est de pas être très
très haut dans les conférences donc ça
ne dérangera pas et construire au tour
de bras de débiles ou un versement de 10
rebonds john olivas bien revenir on va
trés debra débile et on va garder
l'équipe telle qu'elle est l'équipe de
john hall alors y avait des amis dans le
chat qui ils sont plutôt fan de pizzas
shinken alors je ne peux pas leur en
vouloir moi aussi qui est ce que tu t'es
un peu renseigné sur le joueur est ce qu
on demande à manu différentes
je veux bien parce que il n'a pas été
encore qu'à août à washington comme
comme rédiger d'ailleurs n'a pas été vu
par l'usaid à warcq un grand nom d'un
gigantesque way dans le top 10 lors le
j'ai sous les yeux on a vu kobe white
des white est peut-être un peu nasirli
tel scandale richie et nassir little des
deux en fait très forte impression
auprès des observateurs
ainsi aussi que comment il s'appelle
déjà
thaler qu'elle donne qu'elle devienne
voilà que c'est les trois joueurs qu'on
ne manquerait une très forte impression
lors des work out ouais ok manu alors
fidji washington qu'est ce que est ce
que tu peux en dire à notre ami baise
box est un joueur qui peut jouer je
pense qu'on sera meilleurs potes
[Musique]
4les ses qualités moi j'aime bien ça
je pense que ça moyen terme sur le fait
qu'il puisse vraiment être une arme à
trois points dont un peu dans le style
kevin love qui va si c'est shooter à
trois points mais qu'au fil des années
il va devenir encore meilleur est
vraiment vraiment efficace là dedans et
ça j'aime beaucoup d'appétence pour le
tir mais c'est peut-être pour ça mais
mais ça j'aime beaucoup et un jour que
bas ces niveaux ancien du pouvoir la
trempe comment ça va se faire en nba
mais un joueur qui est capable aussi de
quelques petits mousses qui sait se
servir d'eux au panier mais ça je trouve
ça vraiment intéressant
jean leonetti ou que ce genre de choses
qui maîtrisent vraiment pas mal donc
après faut voir face à des joueurs qui
seront plus grand parce qu'on a une si
vieille jouer vraiment quatre voire cinq
je vois plutôt 4 il y avait deux trois
gros bébés uniques richard's et et quand
il s'appelait su que telma dj wiwi les
quatre premiers mois d'un coup plus
massive aux plus grands donc est ce qu
il arrivera parce que jouer de sa et de
avoir gardé ses qualités pour ça ce
transfert dans une vielle h et on était
un petit bémol mais je pense qu'il avoue
rêve d'un vrai potentiel et qui peut
vraiment vraiment s'améliorer qui
s'appelle vraiment une bonne pioche en
neuf ça c'est pas forcément joueurs var
qui gênait en nfl c'est un peu le profil
que décrivait thomas tout à l'heure
néanmoins stretch fort amener du space
singh
il faut s'arracher c'est un devin
d'envergure de tête des vrais outils
défensif des des pieds pas mauvais s'ils
s'améliorent un peu sur la défense à
l'opposé la décence des clips etc
il ya pas mal à aimer sur son potentiel
de mec qui peut switcher de 3,4
il a mis des shoots de plus en plus
difficile au jeu de transition
vraiment franchement il ya beaucoup à
aimer c'est ce jour ben le décrivait ben
qui est parti mais qui était leur début
d'émission il décrit comme le glou gars
est parfait alors est ce que est ce que
ça va avec un peu votre timeline wizard
je sais pas et je pense que t'en penses
est ce que devrait faire le reste est un
mec qui a peut-être un plafond un peu
plus haut un peu plus de potentiel entre
little genre de choses ouais je pense
que là il vaut mieux drafté sur le
potentiel
parce que comment sait pas trop ce qu'on
va faire de nos frenchies gaillard il
vaut mieux essayer de s'assurer un peu
l'avenir après midi à washington
pourquoi pas il s'inscrit bien dans la
philosophie de jeu qu'on a actuellement
avec 1,4 à ses shooteurs comme on a pu
voir quand il ya des marquises maurice
comme le faisait très beau ariza ou même
bobby portis s'est montré ce qu'il s'en
va il reste ses toiles et n'attendent le
plan lui a envie de rester
notre franchise aimerait le garder mais
ça ça dépendra toujours du prix quoi il
est restrictive donc à tout moment une
franchise du proposera 20 millions par
an mais ça va être compliqué pas de deux
versions s'alignent pas comme thomass
bryant je pense qu'elles lui franchise
qui n'hésiteront pas peut-être à lui
mettre 16 millions par an enfin pas tant
de monde que celle qui est du cap
voilà c'est ça donc pas beaucoup de caps
mais il suffit que tu signalé 14 sur my
hand 15 / portis 12 sur sa tour ans qui
était déjà dans la merde
sachant que tu as encore les 17 de
maille me soit sous les épaules et
encore un effectif à construire même si
tu gagnes 20 millions sur jean-marie
parker je n'espère pas qu'ils vont match
et l'option bien qu'il soit très
apprécié par le premier service ça fait
quand même beaucoup 100 millions pour
mutiler par kraft ouais parce que groen
feld à l'époque où je la voulais
absolument garder parker qui t'a à
prendre l'option n'avait millions et
winter s'est en partie c'est vraiment là
je te dis bon comme celle des plus là
qu'est ce qu'on fait est-ce que lui va
avoir accepté de rester avec un contrat
pub tissage en doute sa donc c'est assez
compliqué de
l'effectif tel qu'il est actuellement a
montré de belles choses pas suffisamment
pouvoir remonter finir en perf mais ça a
montré vraiment des qualités donc tu
peux te dire est-ce qu'on peut pas
essayer de négocier peut-être des petits
contrats d'un an on voit si la
mayonnaise prend vraiment et on prend
une décision où on casse tout et on
reconstruit vraiment quoi - k c'est ça
le truc c'est que tant qu'on n'aura pas
un general manager pour dire on va faire
ça ça ça on va garder ce cap rouge parce
qu'on veut développer les jeunes qu'on
va aller chercher etc etc
c'est assez compliqué de se projeter pas
c'est c1 c'est compliqué de se projeter
thomas est ce que que toi tu posait la
question tout à l'heure mais toi tu
serais même prêt à finalement bazarder
ebi les rôles
je pense qu'ils sont dans des cats
complètement différent je pense que bill
a une valeur marchande énorme à l'heure
actuelle où elle beaucoup moins bon non
seulement parce qu'il est blessé pendant
un an mais même parce que derrière ces
trois ans entre 40 et ses 46 millions il
me semble pour un joueur qui a montré
quand même des limites dans son
leadership qui viendra à cora entre 29
et 30 2
un bon âge mais après être venu une
grosse blessure c'est pas la même chose
que bill qui va être entre 25 et 28 ans
prochaines années de contrat
en plus il ya un point qui paraît un peu
évident dans le sens où les pélicans qui
viennent qui veulent un peu se
débarrasser de leurs pics 4 et viennent
de prendre ball et ingram qui vont jouer
un étroit qui vont prendre williamson
qui va jouer quatre pas avoir un poste 2
qui shoote au milieu de cette équipe là
c'est un peu évident donc elle qu' il ya
un tintin divison plein de pistes de
draft sur les prochaines années
oui moi je pense que je repartirais pour
une reconstruction entrer dans ville
ensemble et en essayant de les choper
des au tour de draft et en essayant de
repartir avec potentiellement des pics 4
et 9 un peu de cap pour l'année
prochaine et le retour de wall et
repartir sur là dessus plutôt que sur un
espèce d'intermédiaire avec une équipe
qu'il a dans tous les cas l'année
prochaine va pas jouer des rôles de
deux containers avec un pic 9 et bradley
bill même s'il rechigne quelques bons
contrats avec sa tendance qui autres
ouais la question c'est un petit peu qui
sacrifiait parmi les deux et c'est vrai
que la cote de lille est nécessairement
plus haute que celle de wall si l'on se
place vraiment sur un point de vue
purement financier mais voilà l'intérêt
de bazarder l'un ou l'autre et pas sur
le sentiment disque on sent bien dans le
chat que dit il il est largement favori
dans le coeur des fans ce qui est
d'ailleurs marrant parce que c'était
passé il ya un mois et demi a baissé
depuis deux ans et la mascotte mais
pendant les deux premières années de son
contrat il a souvent été blessé les deux
jeunots elle était au top
et quand vous pouvez en faire avoir les
deux à 100% c'est le journal qui a eu
des soucis avec son genou qui jouait sur
une jambe et bilal on n'a jamais eu les
deux à 100% donc on sait jamais on
n'aura jamais su si ça voulait vraiment
marcher pas donc il serait d après pour
en revenir à l'exemple non pendant la
draft des amis puis back skate on avait
très des bars des bills avec les lakers
pour récupérer le choix 4 donc il quand
même fait cette décision là et on avait
beaucoup discuté offre ne pas essayer de
traiter oil aussi avec notre choix 9
pour justement créé beaucoup de deux
caps space sur cette année et les années
suivantes quoi vraiment repartir presque
presque de zéro de tête je crois que le
trade avec les suns c'est un truc du
genre est liée aux coûts beau joe
jackson et pij est au coeur c'est quand
il s'appelle dj aux arènes
tidjy warren contre wall et le choix 9
ha oui c'est pas beaucoup mais le but
c'était de de dégraisser assez
activement du moins entre deux machines
ça passe et après bien sûr là c'était
vraiment on se débarrasse de waele
quitte à le brader un peut de toute
façon les dés sont eux et eux ils s'en
foutent de pas l'avoir pendant un an tu
sais pas comment il va revenir tu
récupères quand même deux beaux jeunes
et joueurs que quand même pas mal pris
et ceux qui traînent ça reste quand même
assez fiable même si je vois phoenix dj
warren c1 ça plante c'est mettre le
ballon dans le panier
exactement c'est ça donc joe jackson sa
demande qu'à être développé comme au
cobo donc et dans l'optique où on aurait
peut-être gardé scott brooks tu mettais
pas mal de jeunes puisque dans le trade
avec les lakers ont récupéré l'eau nous
sommes dans le plan du golfe ont
récupéré art in all seasons au art et
écoulement c'est le prêt de qu'on avait
négocié avec avec d'amples amis de chez
baker et faire donc
donc oui c'était la draft circuit basket
tu disais que ça donc on a quand même
choisi de sacrifier ben il s'était posé
la question john volent bas au final or
on l'a pas fait mais c'est m une
question qu'on s'est posée donc et en
tout est rentré dans les deux tu pouvais
potentiellement récupérer six joueurs et
du coup tu avais déjà plus de
flexibilité pour choisir qui gardait sur
l'avenir avec tes restricted prenable et
quoi absolument est ce que tu as des
questions sur d'autres et dans le chat
aussi des questions sur d'autres
prospects actuellement tu pourras être
chez vous mais moi personnellement
j'aimais beaucoup romeo langford qu'on
n'a pas vu qui aurait pu être une
solution assez sympa derrière bradley
bill qui manque peut-être un peu deux
shoots mais qui défensivement leurs
effets du taf assez solide avec une
seconde unité a besoin de défendre ça a
été notre souci ces deux dernières
saisons on avait cinq majeur qui creusé
des écarts et on perdait totalement la
vence avec la semaine et alors
manu sur langford est-ce que tu y crois
en hollande fort des censeurs jeu
antoine y croit moyen
moi je crois plutôt fort moi je chante
les de washoe moyens près moi ma
principale interrogation c'est ça va
être son poignet est-ce que ça va ça va
bien tu résorber la tient dimanche que
toute la saison avec moi même il trois
saisons avec
un bandage et une avait trouvé une
blessure aux ligaments du pouce sur sam
a ajouté celui mois depuis plusieurs
années d'ailleurs sur les images il a
déjà au moins 11 en deux ans donc ça va
plus est là dessus après je pense moi je
trouve peut-être encore un peu soft ça
va ça va arriver - ou encore un peu
sortent après défensivement moi j'entre
c'est pareil c'est un peu comme ready
c'est un joueur a envie d'y croire qu'on
sent que tu sens qu'il ya quelque chose
que là c'est pareil que ce qu'il a fait
le bon choix en allant rihanna c'est
pareil c'est est ce que dans une autre
équipe il a regretté
enfin dans un autre université il aurait
été un peu plus cadré et du coup avec un
peu moins de responsabilités mais du
coup on est en étant un peu plus
prolifique
oui du coup ça change ça change tout là
il a voulu rester chez lui
proche de proches de sa famille et tout
et tout donc ça un choix qui se respecte
il ya pas de soucis mais mais je moi
franchement ça qui me plaît bien être
plus depuis assez longtemps
j'aime bien sa capacité à attaquer le
cercle comme si parfois tendance à et
d'aller y aller tête baissée mais ça
j'aime beaucoup et son tir est
constamment tout va se jouer là dessus
on sent des plus gros comme on dit swing
ski le droit draft si roméo langue ford
en tire je vois pas pourquoi il frappait
une carrière de dix ans dans le
titulaire l'important c'est absolument
ça merci manu pour promo langford merci
belle fini avec la question habituelle
c'est quoi le scénario idéal
le scénario idéal de demain soir de
trait des bradeux lehbila ou pelikan si
je pense prendre qu à l'heure de rédiger
et de voir qu'est ce qu'on peut
construire juste des briques les années
prochaines
bien sûr brain débile de partir d'autres
pépites 4 surtout avec tous les pays qui
l'ont récupéré des bikers et si un
joueur tu dois
récupérer des détroits lakers la turquie
j'aimerais bien de chartres c'est un
joueur que j'apprécie énormément
messieurs a du goût merci beaucoup mais
avec plaisir d'observer si beaucoup
bonne soirée à toi et lui qui est arrivé
c'est ça ou pas ce qui vient d'arriver
en corner oui on te voit
bonsoir comment vas-tu luc impeccable
lui qui est aux fidèles sur twitter
notamment et qui est fan du magic parler
alors qu'est ce que tu peux nous dire
sur sur tes attentes pour demain soir
sur le magic qu'alpiq 16 hockey c'est
pas pareil j'ai forcément hyper
intéressant mais il ya peut-être des
quoi faire iliad il a toujours des quoi
faire maintenant il ya qu'on y aille
avec man du front au fisc qui a parlé il
ya hirsch roi et qu'a dit qu'il
prendrait le meilleur joueur disponible
qui pourrait aider l'équipe
immédiatement maintenant à savoir
qu'est-ce qui vous voit pouvoir va
pouvoir prendre parce que je trouve
qu'il ya beaucoup de trous à combler
dans l'équipe parce que à certains
postes
après moi la priorité ça serait un
shooting world post 2 oui alors c'est à
dire que pour que fournier cc tu fais
une crois tu n'ont pas forcément parce
qu'après en pixels on a l'a vu les
joueurs qu'il ya toujours possibilité
d'avoir un bon joueur je crois par
exemple si on prend un ami quel
alexander walker
il ya possibilité d'avoir un kevin
porter le numéro 6 il descend il ya
après il faut en effet il y aura droit à
ce moment-là de la dhr assurera du soir
il y aura beaucoup de risques
alors toi est ce que tu préfères à la
question c'est est-ce que tu prennes
faire plus plus de risques et plus de
potentiel ou finalement plus plus
d'assurance et peut-être un potentiel un
peu moins grand alors moi je préférais
déjà way plus un joueur prêt déjà
offensivement parce que par rapport au
pic des dernières années je trouve qu'on
a on a pris beaucoup de joueurs
défensifs en aide
on a eu une très bonne équipe défensive
quelle est la meilleure progression ça a
été la surprise année
mais c'est vrai que niveau offensif
quand je prends garde bamba qui est très
bon défensivement mais après
offensivement c'est pas ça du tout cette
année c'est durant wacey windu c'est la
même chose même si s'améliorer cette
année en espérant qu'ils s'améliorent
mais plus dans les shoots à 2.6 a
amélioré d'un shoot à trois points
je trouve qu'on a une grosse équipe mais
forte défensivement maintenant il
faudrait un joueur et avec beaucoup de
potentiel pour l'avenir que c'est sûr ça
c'est sûr ça qu'ils ont misé avec isaac
bamba et yaron gordon qui avait plus
anciens maintenant on va dire maintenant
il faudrait joueurs qu'ils soient plus
prêt à prendre les postes maintenant à
marquer plus de points 6 et 8 il nous
faut des joueurs comme alexander walker
adore ce style là où même kevin porter
junior qui aurait contraint est très
fort et c'est peut-être ça qui nous
manque pour faire la différence mais il
est très mauvais au lancer-franc donc
oui c'est un peu ce qui est inquiétant
chez lui tôt thomas tu partages
l'analyse de luxe et c'est vraiment il
faut de plaintes a quand même temps ce
plusieurs années ouais alors pense qu'il
manque du talent offensif à à orlando
après est ce que c'est vraiment avec le
pic 16 qui vont trouver un joueur qui va
qui va changer le visage offensif de la
franchise je suis pas je suis pas
certain je pense que le talent il sera
peut-être apporté par le pari sur foule
ce qu'ils ont fait qui normalement
revenir l'année prochaine a priori après
le terrain'' strauss je pense que va
probablement partir moi je vois bien un
poste un poste 3 un peu trendy bon au
shoot pour décaler isaac plus sur une
rotation post 4 avec avec aaron gordon
qui est à mon avis plus son poste
naturel il a été décalé isaac beaucoup 3
cette année un poste 2-3 après si
j'avoue que sur ces milieux de draft je
me connais un peu moins alors après ce
que c'est roméo langue forte qu'elle
donne johnson le joueur le meilleur
joueur qui sera disponible sur ces
postes là
à ce moment là mon avis c'est ce qu'ils
doivent c'est ce qu'ils doivent plus
plus visés avec 1,5 qui se construire
mon avis autour de foule c'est une
raquette gordon gordon bande basse et
jamais vous ceviche pas et par signés
essentiellement des postes de 3 autour
de autour de fournier potentiellement
d'un jeune d'un jeune qui soit signé
dans la draft manu qui est ce que tu
préfères dans ce serait entre 15 et 20
avec ce profil de aller post 2 pour
l'udc
post 3 pour thomas voilà des gens qui
peuvent shooter surtout qu apporte un
petit peu de création offensive aussi
s'il est disponible
moi je vais sur matière dit elle même
s'il shooter pas vraiment il à bien
shooter en work out alors en un conte 0
encore une fois je suis pas très fan il
faut il faut donc toi nasir little dans
ce sens rennes je l'avais alexander
walker après mais c'est l'indication
sied sur foot s'en fait comment comment
il va revenir s'il revient c'est juste
ça ce que s'y retrouve son niveau de
washington est-ce qu'il ya besoin d'un
meneur français ou anecdotes peut être
trouvé entre d'une fille mais autrement
moi je partir la pression s'il est en
forme pure 1 2 3
donc ce sera à l'it langford porteurs
n'ont pas forcément beaucoup beaucoup
fans pouvoir qu adam johnson se soit
26,5 qu'elle donne johnson ça ressemble
un peu au mix de ce que voulait lui
qu'est de ce que voulait thomas c'est du
2 3 ça choque un petit peu ça défend pas
mal alors le potentiel de création est
limité mais il est plus ce n'est
peut-être plus nba reddick que nasir
little ou que
ou que qui est ce qu'un site et kevin
porter d'union voilà donc donc pourquoi
pas après tout quelqu'un johnson même si
je crois que detroit qui piquent juste
avant et à ses chaussures sur lui ce qui
pourrait rendre les choses difficiles
luc vous ceviche qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
mais est-ce clair c'est avec la saison
qu'on a eu cette année la saison
surprise en liant ce que s'ils étaient
assis on était haut comme tout les comme
toutes les années ont baissé de niveau à
partir de janvier on se retrouvait dans
la loterie
peut-être qu'on aurait très d'avant
maintenant avec ses clips ford il a été
boosté en défense est impressionnant
l'équipe c booster défensivement aussi
il a été indispensable
c'est ça le souci qu est ce qu on leur
assigne à ce que leurs six mois si on ne
signe pas on se retrouve avec bamba et
mos def
alors avec bamba est un fantôme plutôt
un fantôme qui coûtent 17 millions de
francs et l'infante un fantôme qui
coûtent 17 millions ben c'est sa
dernière année voilà je sais enfin un
free agent là on a tout le monde qui est
partie mcmichael car soeurs williams qui
a bien aidé free agent
parce que briscoe s'était blessé et
briscoe de ce que je peux suivre de
instagram et ses suites et bien rester
sur orlando et travaille avec l'équipe
donc il n'est pas impossible qu'il leur
signe pour faire un backup avec foule
c'est augustine et briscoe ensuite c'est
quid de terrain strauss et quid de vous
ces huit genres vous c'est vite sur lui
donne ouais c'est un maximum d'un
million quoi mais c'est pareil
il nous reste 20 3 millions de cap comme
je dis mais mam en poste 4 bury les
frais à john gerald martin les frais
jones il nous reste que gordon
donc c'est pareil est ce que si un pic à
washington des sens à ce qu'il vaudrait
mieux pas prendre 16 je sais pas en plus
c'est moi qui suis fan de kentucky donc
qu'elle donne johnson du washington
ouais c'est des joueurs qui se sentent
plutôt indisponible tu vu si tu pourras
en avoir un des trois oui c'est possible
c'est pour ça en poste 4 si on sait
jamais si pitching tonnes décembre et ça
peut être une grosse plus-value après j
c est beau je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup
de points d'interrogations après un free
agent
si les hornets vu comment ils sont
partis pour quoi pour essayer de
récupérer jeremy lamb genre ça c'est ça
parce que le poste de pivot il peut
aussi se combler par la free agency cia
ne rechigne pas moi j'ai dans ma box
génitales et norton de coeur parce que
c'est un joueur qui crée beaucoup en
tout cas qui a le potentiel de créer
beaucoup il jouait plutôt un d'eux quand
ils étaient plus jeunes cette année il
joue à +23 mais voilà énorme potentiel
talenton de coeur c'est un peu ça colle
c'est un peu la carte joker de cet art
qu'est ce que dans cinq ans ça
correspond plus aux types de l'équipe
avec les mensurations
ah oui c'est ça ben moi c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles des mais là
c'est que rolando il adore graft et des
longs bras et alors taylor côté coeur il
a de m cette d'envergure pour pour 1 m m
1,13 de tai-chi suis dis pas de bêtises
donc voilà plutôt plutôt une espèce de
jeu c'est juste que j'ai pas un animal
avec des longues ailes lui qu'est ce que
tu as des questions sur certains
certains prospects
peut-être pour le pit 46 que vous avez
alors p-dg 46 soit c'est là par contre
c'est surtout par rapport séparé tout
dépend du poste comprendra française bon
après si on se tourne plus vers 1 1 2 1
3 il fait froid renforcé comme jeudi le
poste 4
moi j'avais j'ai ciblé j'avais bien aimé
l'année dernière et puis cette année
aussi
dedrick l'automne de kansas mois que
j'aime bien qui apparaît ou qui
disparaît démographe
ouais il ya une saison très décevante
mais le potentiel hydrique là puisqu'il
faisait tous les alpes ce mythe
c'est nice madrid aussi ses marques
donc voilà après absolument absolument
une fois qu'ils voient que je suis bien
je suis bien l'actualité aussi
universitaire et high school manu l'az
rite ca
c'est un peu risqué parce qu'il va pas
très sérieux j'ai l'impression dans son
conditionnement des jarres en terre
inconnue j'avais bien qu'on était un peu
plus jeunes savent eux ne perdent en vue
au tournoi de turin n'en trévise prend
d'entrée vidéo dit oui j'avais bien aimé
son agressivité moi je moi pas de ce qui
est devenu en fait ouais c'est un alors
une force incroyable c'est peut-être que
le joueur le plus fort de la draft
si en fin de concours je sais pas de
gens qui se rentrent dedans qui se
poussent genre de choses mais mais après
en termes voilà en terme de basket faire
des aller retour et c'est le moteur et
dignité
il est trop gras après avec un bon
conditionnement c'est un bon joueur qui
a dû toucher mais après il va falloir
qu'il capte un petit peu comment comment
défendre puisque pour les intérieurs
c'est encore plus important aujourd'hui
je pense que pour les joueurs extérieurs
après déjà bien le chameau riponne son
deuxième tour cha morricone c'est pas
mal si vous n'êtes plus un backup pong
et ça effectivement on a parlé hier
chamois réponse du joueur de st john's
taille correcte pour un 2 qui peut
scorer en peu en micro ondes
mais qui sait aussi j faire jouer les
joueurs genre de choses
donc qu'est ce qu'on peut souhaiter
c'est quoi pour toi le les envies pour
le soir de la draft les envie pas déjà
si péter washington peut glisser pour
qu'on comprenne pourquoi pas mais après
je pense qu'ils resteront sur le 16h46
ils chercheront pas un goujat ça c'est
sûr
ils ont rien à proposer et puis ils
perdraient trop je trouve il perdrait
trop gros et après je ne sais pas qui
soit comme les eaux les années d'avant
être intelligent c'est pareil on a vu
j'ai vu une photo de foule ce qui est
revenu à l'amway center aujourd'hui pour
s'entraîner donc voilà donc sap résume
bien il a dit que bettman a dit qu'il
était bien donc voilà puis tu vois je
n'ose s'y glisse ça m'irait bien
mouais alors allez piger qui glisse et
et dans une urne billets qui bouge
beaucoup finalement un peu de stabilité
tu te dis que ça peut ça peut peut-être
payé ouais bon merci merci beaucoup
d'avoir été là luc doyen merci à vous
c'est un plaisir très sympa et on attend
évidemment aussi demain si tu es encore
debout alors de la draft je vais la
suivre
après il ne savait pas si elle est
diffusée sur des chaînes américaines le
deuxième tour surtout parce que en
diffuse deux premiers mais je n'arrive
pas à voir le deuxième tour le deuxième
tour c'est une bonne question est est ce
qu'il s'arrête à verser un premier temps
je sais pas je crois qu'ils alternent en
fait ils parlent du premier tour et
quand il ya un bon choix ou une bonne
équipe il dans when he est ce possible
c'est possible donc je pense qui
espionnent sera en diffusion et qui
garde un plateau il espionne et
l'adoption il ya eu plein de d'accord
c'est avoir de ce côté là allez bonne
soirée luc réparé moi merci merci à toi
on termine thomas par les suns
on n'a pas de représentant des suns mais
mais c'est une franchise capcom un pic
dans le top 10 donc est ce que tu peux
nous faire diagnostic tient alors ce jeu
faut soit avoir de lancre dans le stylo
pour dresser le diagnostic des scènes
ouais c'est une équipe qui manque un peu
de tout
alors après il ya quand même pas mal de
potentiel dans cette équipe et aussi pas
mal d'à 7 à échanger notamment dj warren
joe jackson qui a eu des problèmes en
plus à phoenix donc je pense que c'est
une équipe qui va chercher à bouger à la
draft notamment particulier en plus ils
sont ils sont ils ont un pic si ce qui
pourrait les amener à avoir garlande
qu'obi wan je peux être sûr qu'ils
soient fanatiques forcément d'un des
dards joueurs ni de re drafté compte
tenu du nombre de jeunes qu'ils ont moi
je m'attendais à ce qu'il fasse un push
plus fort pour pour mike conley mai mais
visiblement ils ont été ils ont été
dépassés par utah je les vois bien
essayé quand même de récupérer un meneur
vétéran avec les avec les assets qu'ils
ont notamment entrer dans pourquoi pas
tyler johnson tidji warren joe jackson
et en utilisant ce pick six pour avoir
un meneur vétéran est potentiellement un
poste un poste 4
alors s'ils n'arrivent pas à trade et
pourquoi pas prendre typiquement d andré
enter s'il est encore disponible en 6
sinon je pense que il guidera ferons pas
et qui est qui et qui seront un meneur
vétéran type on a parlé pourquoi pas de
chris paul même si ça a été démenti
jeff teague john wall a voilà jeff
teague john ball cdc des idées mais je
suis pas sûr qu'ils se retrouvent à
draft et du coup à ce moment là ils ont
quand même plus besoin de deux vétérans
poste un poste 4
ce qu'ils avaient ici l'année dernière
avec un visa et moins de jeunes talents
ils ont déjà booker michael bridge is on
sent que t'es pas un kobe white
enthousiaste à ce que chaque fois tu
préfères créé dès que graftech toby
white
bah en fait je sais c'est pour toutes
ces équipes là mon avis qu'ils ont moins
besoin d'un joueur comme comme kobe
white mai
mais après bon c'est à voir je pense que
la cobi white booker aura beaucoup la
balle en main ils ont besoin plutôt d'un
meneur un peu gestionnaire de vétérans
défensif qui est moins le profil de kobe
hoa et du coup absolument absolument
manu tu étais plutôt d'accord avec cette
analyse cette part est un peu léger que
c'est dwight ce que ça soit white
garlande pour apporter tout de suite à
une équipe de phoenix mais j'ai
l'impression que plus la droite proche
mois ils ont envie de rareté de me lire
si on a beaucoup parlé d'eux qu'ils
étaient ultra chaussures guerlande au
tout début
après s'est passé à white maintenant
c'est plus trop si crd de aussi c'est du
colvert hunter donc c'est étrange ce qui
se passe à phoenix moi je comprends pas
trop ce qu'ils recherchent
moi j'ai perdu six disponibles j'ai
réussi ont dû bien longtemps je pensais
aller que après c'est toujours c'est
défensivement mais on peut on peut être
mon sens sont être trop défensif
carmelo de la montre et james harden a
montré il est dit pas qu'il aura ce
talent là offensivement je suis pas ça
mais non mais accueilli peut à la fois
spots up est à la fois créer un petit
peu sur le pick and roll je trouve pas
pour moi non mais bien sûr vous donner
des avis personnels de toute façon on
n'est pas on n'est pas dans le front
office des phoenix suns donc donc ques
les besoins évidents imposteur un post 4
alors après ils ont aussi le pic 32 qui
est pas si bas que ça et qui est dans
une zone où on pourrait avoir des des
restes c'est pas très gentil de dire que
ça avec des joueurs qui restent elles
auront peut-être échappé à la vigilance
des équipes plus haute tour eiffe des
bons restera exactement comme un
lendemain de mariage donc
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir à ce
niveau-là du samaa nietzsche à l'horizon
peut-être ils en ont peut-être un peu
goûté de l'expérience du 4 blanc qui
pestent samanides chez skoda d'autres
idées jallet mcdaniels a fait voir ce
que ça peut donner
ben aziz un chris weitz dont je parlais
hier au pied et avant-hier juste passe
de trois du coup way occupant un peu
c'est du dépannage qui peut dépanner je
prends tu après il ya eu exactement ça
c'est vraiment le pic qui pourrait se
trouver par là avec du fort potentiel
il risque apparemment dû lui on sait pas
trop où le maître comme vient pas jouer
de la saison c'est un peu délicat de se
baser que sur work out alors rejouer je
ne sais pas lequel il a rencontré pour
parler avec eux mais qui sait que se
baser sur lyn thériault vendredi
l'entretien
c'est un peu léger je trouve ouais mais
ça me paraît qu'il tente ça dépend qui
avec l équipe tu as envie de voir thomas
disait disait plutôt trouver du vétéran
et ça fait un peu de sens puisque
l'équipe est très jeune et peut-être
qu'il manque un petit peu d'impact en
fait de gens qui n'ont mais du vétéran
via trade cc6 à marianne chaillac il est
grand père je crois mais sinon oui et
non c'est ça que tu voulais dire un
thomas c'est être aidé pour des joueurs
d'expérience ouais je pense qu'ils ont
besoin plus de deux vétérans là c'est à
peu près il me semble que les 31 l'année
dernière où ils avaient drafté au cobo
ils ont déjà quand même beaucoup de
joueurs même
même deux jeunes espoirs qui compte pas
forcément enfin qui comportait dans la
rotation au cobo melton mais qu'y avoir
mit cambridge je suis pas sûr qu'il
veuille encore ajouter un joueur
le cas échéant peut-être plutôt à
l'intérieur alors pourquoi pas en grenat
street à l'heure où j'ai vu qu'il y
avait que wade et rieuse bazelais aussi
danser dans ces eaux là alors certes il
ya pas eu de la saison mais je pense
qu'il ya peut-être des équipes qui vont
être attirés par le fait que c'était un
peu les mêmes doutes je me souviens
qu'on avait sur michelle robinson
l'année dernière à la même époque a été
plutôt ça a été plutôt positif ouais
peut-être plutôt à l'intérieur mais
effectivement moi je l'utiliserai plus
plus les pics pour pour trait d pour
traiter pour des joueurs vétérans et
sinon dans le dans ceux qui sont dans le
raid du pick six éventuellement plus je
trouve que le profit de hunter footer
bon défenseur
à côté de dayton peut bien aller mais
messi n'ont pas su poète pas sûr que je
l'utilisent si je suis un jam de phoenix
manu il changer leur choix en fait une
autre on ne refuse pas même si vous
regardez ces choix là s'il s'est trompé
oui c'est assez difficile il n'y a pas
eu trop trop de rumeurs pour l'instant
il me semble tomates et peut-être un peu
plus peut-être plus un deuil sur ça que
nous mais ils ne semblent pas avoir vu
il y avait des rumeurs connaît mais à
part ça je vais me bouger dans l'andra
trois temps oui il ya eu une rumeur un
peu chris paul aussi à un moment dans la
mesure où ils ont pas mal de caps donc
il pouvait aussi absorber un trade on en
voyant de l'autre côté pourquoi pas
tidjy warren et joe jackson par exemple
les laisser un peu plus de flexibilité à
houston mais ça a été plutôt démenti
côté côté houston récemment le départ de
chris paul donc tu vois pas forcément
non plus de noms plus d'évidence darius
garlande moi j'avoue que je suis un peu
plus ces petites bêtes courte garlande
booker déjà je pense que défensivement
ils souffrent déjà pas mal ce serait
quand même vraiment compliqué les deux
vont quand même besoin d'avoir pas mal
de la balle en main
moi c'est quand même un peu moins un peu
moins évident que l'aurait été une paire
avec avec caunes l'est où chris paul est
entré dans ce pic 6 oui bon en tout cas
on va conclure là dessus je pense sauf
si toi même tu avais des questions pour
tournon pour qu'on puisse se conclure
sur l'analyse tel ou tel joueur mais
sinon voyages et thomas web ainsi si
vous deviez faire là un pari sur le le
donovan mitchell de cette grave tout le
bois mais qui est au delà peut-être du
top 7 8 qu'on a tous en tête qui va
devenir qu'un potentiel en tout cas pour
devenir plus qu'un rôle player aller
manu que tu veux que je m'élance où tu
as des idées c'est l'heure de se
mouiller de façon ouais moi j'ai deux
idées c'est baptiste diebold nicolas
claxton intéressant donc là vraiment des
joueurs pour inciter le probablement
plus autour de la 20e place
je pense que même si toutes tailles ball
est un peu plus vieux
je pense que c'est de voir conquois un
plafond à ces enfin potentiellement tu
as perdu manu au moment le plus
intéressant bon mathis title qui est un
joueur qui ont la grosse question elle
shoot dommage parce qu un peu grosse
question sur le shoot mais un
probablement un des meilleurs défenseurs
voir le meilleur défenseur de ces deux
retours manu oui ça nous a coupé au
total et parler de taille donne ah non
je disais qu'il y avait un fief du
potentiel même s'il était un peu plus
âgée qui avait quand même un potentiel à
gratter bon
op arrivés manu sort sort de cette cave
m'a dit que c'était la chaîne starz une
cave
et moi je vais te donner les miens
rapidement pour moi le pull sur entre
guillemets parce que justement à ce
niveau la draft rien n'est sûr mais pour
moi le plus sûr et à celui à qui manque
le moins serono lencquesaing et on en a
parlé tout à l'heure et un autre dont on
a aussi parlé tout à l'heure et moi le
plafond est extrêmement haut c'est à la
norton coeur voilà mais c'est plus dans
deux ans soit entre que roméo aussi ici
s'il arrive à acheter dès l'année
prochaine
ça peut ça peut faire ça peut faire du
mal
alors ok et peut-être dernière question
je pense que je pense qu'il ya quand
même pas mal d'équipés qui vont se poser
cette question aussi c'est une draft où
j'ai l'impression que tout le monde
s'accorde à dire qu'au delà du top 3 et
surtout le top 8 d'une draft d'un niveau
un peu moyen comme trame ans
contrairement à l'année passée où il y
avait vraiment des énormes potentiels et
pour vous ça a du sens même si c'est
peut-être un peu tôt pour le dire pour
des équipes de laisser passer un peu
cette draft ou de trait des leurres leur
pic cette année pour le top de l'année
prochaine ou est ce qu'il n'ya pas de
gros prospects qui s'annonce pour
l'année prochaine vas-y manu tu connais
bien quelques pros scott pour 2020 mais
ça c'est ça a l'air d'être sur le papier
un petit peu plus costaud que ça n'est
pas énormément mais ouais cette année
s'il vraiment une grappe de role players
en fait parler les trois premiers c'est
vraiment des joueurs ou c'est ça c'est
le tir 3 qui est décevant en fait on va
attendre d'eux qu'ils répondent à des un
système qui rentrent plus dans un rôle
bien précis que ce soit défensivement ou
offensivement que tu fais du foot voilà
qui va vraiment avoir un rôle précis et
répondent à cela et je pense pas que ce
sera des joueurs qui font gagner ou ce
sera des facteur x comme on a vu la
vendre lucas en finale kaka montré que
c'était au final c'est un super joueur
mais ce sera de ce calibre là en fait
pour moi
et prochainement du sort du lot en
collant tony ouais bah je pense qu'il ya
le suit a le plus de potentiel dans dont
la drogue 2020 c'est james weightman
doit jouer à memphis l'année prochaine
qui est un intérieur qui sait vraiment
qui est vraiment intéressant
rim protector qui va encore améliorer
son shoot c'est peut-être son plus gros
point faible à l'heure actuelle mais
autrement je pense que c'est là le plus
gros potentiel
après tu as tu un arrière anthony
edwards dont les américains raffolent
moi j'ai pas en compte 3 malgré pas mal
pas mal de choix notamment sur les
lignes arrières je rajoute à salé les
deux français cole anthony les comme
agnone pearl jam turn qu'il faut pas
oublier même s'il ira chez chez bell en
australie ouais ben gardane quarts est
mana heart george quinn précieux
stéphanois jérémy à robinson heures je
pense que le cep est une très bonne
pioche donc tu es déjà le fait qu'on
arrive à en citer à peu près autant en
en avance quand même plutôt une bonne
blague d'année prochaine
vrai pacte loterie en fait qui va de
super intéressant c'est ça que les
joueurs c'est ça va venir l'année pour 7
à 10 du coût qui voient de moins de
trois mois
une vraie loterie qui va être
intéressante mais aujourd'hui elle l'est
parce que la fédé ce que c'est ce que
pour répondre à ta question thomas je
pense que ça dépend d'où tu te trouves
dans la draft mais si tu trouves mettons
entre entre 9 et 15
ça vaut le coup pour moi de faire
l'impasse puisque en plus c'est des
équipes qui cherchent un peu un home run
qui cherche à se sortir des situations
où ils sont au capital donc donc ça vaut
le coup de trade et même à la limite
pour avoir que d'être épique des futurs
hits quoi les pics les plus recherchés
ça va devenir l'éthique 2022 normalement
mais mais même
avec la réforme de la loterie des
petites 2020 ça peut être intéressant
donc pour les équipes présentes entre
washington et à l'est orlando roquette
au numéro est paru aux éditions se moque
mais néanmoins il sera beaucoup plus
probablement drafté que l'y angelo
adapté mois ont clos mais pour qui
pourrait être drafté gary un petit
potentiel
merci beaucoup tu auras détresse que si
longtemps c'est très peur merci à vous
et hyper intéressant et puis manu merci
également se voit demain qui devançait
la draf apparatchiks
apparemment il ya un petit truc vers
minuit et demi et il va se passer plein
de choses d'ici là et même pendant très
probablement donc donc suivent et nous
on va essayer de vous tenir informés de
toutes les conséquences et ramifications
que ça peut avoir la draft et puis et
puis voilà si vous avez besoin d'infos
sur un joueur et un autre site qui est
fait pour ça salut tout le monde